Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. This is going to be, in every way, a historic episode. Firstly, because it's the first episode that we've done at a podcast festival. So it's absolutely fantastic to be here. We've been going for less than a year, and so to actually be here and to see you guys, well, I can just about see you guys out there,
感谢收听《历史的 restis》。如果您想每周收听独家加长节目、无广告内容、抢先收听系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的 restis》。这将是一期在各方面都极具历史意义的节目。首先，因为这是我们在播客节上录制的第一期节目。所以来到这里真的非常棒。我们开播还不到一年，能真正来到这里见到大家，好吧，我勉强能看到你们坐在外面，
is really fantastic. So thanks so much for coming. Also, this is going to be a historic episode, because as you can probably tell, even though they have a kind of similar degree of follicle challenge, this is
真的是太棒了。非常感谢大家的到来。另外，这也将是一期具有历史意义的节目，因为正如大家所见，尽管他们的“发量危机”程度相当，但这位
not Dominic. This is Professor Ali Ansari of the University of St. Andrews, Professor of Iranian Studies. And the reason that Ali is here rather than Dominic is because Dominic has only gone and caught COVID. He's over the worst. I think he was quite ill, so I mustn't be horrid about it and accuse him of malingering. I think he was quite ill, so I mustn't be horrid about it and accuse him of malingering. I think he really was ill. And he's on his last day of quarantine, so absolutely terrible timing.
不是多米尼克（Dominic）。这位是圣安德鲁斯大学的伊朗研究教授阿里·安萨里教授（Professor Ali Ansari）。阿里之所以会出现在这里而不是多米尼克，是因为多米尼克竟然感染了新冠。他已经度过了最危险的时期。我想他病得挺重的，所以我可不能刻薄地指责他在装病偷懒。我想他真的病得很重，所以我可不能刻薄地指责他装病偷懒。我想他是真的病了。这正好是他隔离的最后一天，所以时机简直糟糕透顶。
But, you know, every cloud has a silver lining, and the silver lining in this case is Ali. And those of you who are regular listeners to the podcast may well remember the episode we did on Persia, in which Ali, you were set the challenge of basically proving that everything came from Persia. Which I think I did rather well, didn't I? You did. You did.
但是，你知道，天无绝人之路，而这次的“一线生机”就是阿里。经常收听我们播客的朋友可能还记得我们做过的那期关于波斯的节目，当时阿里，你接到的挑战基本上是证明一切都源自波斯。我想我完成得相当不错，对吧？是的，确实不错。
So what was it? It was religion. Empire. High heels. Time. High heels. Suits. Spaghetti, which sort of slightly went off the edge, actually, I have to say. After a while, I got some abuse for that, I have to say.
那么，都有哪些呢？宗教。帝国。高跟鞋。时间。高跟鞋。西装。还有意大利面，其实稍微有点牵强，我必须得承认。过了一段时间后，为此我遭到了不少抨击，我必须承认。
And the British Civil Service. The British Civil Service, I thought was, yeah, I thought was pretty, yeah. Yeah, so if you haven't listened to that, Ali conclusively demonstrating that everything is basically Persian, please do. But the third reason that this is a historic podcast is, of course, because it's about history. And today's episode, we are going to look at the top 10 mistresses in history. And in a way, this is a companion piece to an earlier episode we did,
还有英国公务员制度。英国公务员制度，我觉得，是的，我觉得相当……对。所以，如果你还没听过那一期节目——阿里在其中令人信服地证明了一切基本上都源自波斯——请务必去听听。但我们今天录制这期历史播客的第三个原因，当然是因为它讲的是历史。在今天的节目中，我们要盘点历史上的十大情妇。从某种意义上来说，这是我们之前一期节目的姊妹篇，
the top 10 eunuchs in history. And it's been a kind of running theme, genital mutilation, but we're trying to kind of expand on that. And actually they're similar because what both of them do, firstly, to kind of expand on that and actually they're similar because what both of them do firstly they kind of you know inherently salacious so it does enable us to talk about you know fair degree of filth I suppose but it's not just about the filth
即历史上的十大太监。这似乎成了一个贯穿的主题，关于生殖器切除，但我们正试图在这方面有所拓展。其实它们有相似之处，因为这两者所做的事，首先，为了扩展开来谈，它们其实很相似，因为这两者所做的事，首先，它们天生就带有淫秽的色彩，所以这确实让我们得以谈论相当程度的“下流”内容，我想，但这不仅仅是为了下流，
truly ladies and gentlemen because actually the subject of mistresses I mean Ali it's about those who are powerless rather as with eunuchs it's about those who are powerless rather as with eunuchs it's about those who are powerless having a chance actually to exert influence that's right basically the the ability to exert political influence at quite an intimate level I think it's a way to look at it but but they do exert the influence they do it although as we'll see as we go down the list I mean the some exert less than others but yes so the format we're going to do is we've got we've drawn up ten and Dominic has also had his feedback so he's
女士们先生们，事实上，关于情妇这个主题，我的意思是，阿里，这关乎那些没有权力的人，就像太监一样，这关乎那些没有权力的人，正如太监一样，这关乎那些没有权力的人有机会真正施加影响力。没错，基本上是能够在相当私密的层面上施加政治影响的能力，我认为这是一种看待它的方式。但他们确实施加了影响力，尽管正如我们顺着名单往下看时会看到的，有些人施加的影响力少一些，但确实如此。所以我们采用的形式是：我们列出了十个人，多米尼克也提出了他的反馈，所以他
contributed to this list so the three of us is definitely here in spirit and I will be calling for a friend if I need to so the the three of us have have come up with this basically this top ten and we'll be going from from number ten all the way up to number one the the person we think is the most influential mistress in history and basically the the parameters are you have to have come from nowhere and exerted a kind of incredible influence on the course of history or whatever so that's basically other specifications Ali, do you want to kick off? Because you'll see up there, we've got our first one.
也为这份名单做出了贡献。因此我们三个人的精神绝对都在这里，如果需要的话，我会打电话向朋友求助。所以我们三个人基本上想出了这个前十名，我们将从第十名一直讲到第一名——我们认为历史上最具影响力的情妇。基本上，其基本标准是：你必须出身于微末，却对历史进程等产生了不可思议的巨大影响，所以这就是基本要求。阿里，你想先开始吗？因为你会看到上面写着我们的第一个人选。
At number ten, we have... Yes, the nightingale. The nightingale, who I had never heard of. Yes. But is she in any way Persian? Well, the truth is, yes. Is she influential? Probably not. But it was partly as your means of getting me on this podcast
排在第十位的是……没错，夜莺。夜莺，我以前从未听说过她。是的。但她跟波斯有任何关系吗？好吧，事实是，是的。她有影响力吗？可能没有。但这部分是为了诱使我上这个播客，
that I insisted that we at least have one person on there that came from Persia. And this is... Obviously, when we're looking at the topic of mistresses, it's a bit difficult. As much as I scoured through Persian history and general Islamic history to find, you'll find that the patriarchy is not only entrenched,
我坚持我们至少要在上面写一个来自波斯的人。这就是……显然，当我们审视情妇这个话题时，有点困难。尽管我在波斯历史和一般的伊斯兰历史中苦苦搜寻，你会发现不仅父权制根深蒂固，
but it's probably institutionalised. So what you have is a situation where if you can have many wives and many concubines, mistresses are somewhat surplus to requirements. So it's a bit... It was quite difficult to locate. So the nightingale was basically a concubine rather than a mistress of an early 19th-century Persian king. But she's notable for the influence she exerted on him. And you'll acknowledge, of course, and I'll have to acknowledge,
而且它可能已经制度化了。所以你面临这样一种情况：如果你可以拥有许多妻子和许多妾室，那么情妇在某种程度上就成了多余的。所以这有点……很难找到。因此，夜莺基本上是19世纪初一位波斯国王的妾室，而不是情妇。但她因对国王施加的影响而引人注目。当然，你会承认，我也必须承认，
that the influence was pretty slight because this king had, ooh, I think about 1,000 concubines. But the interesting thing is it was noticed that this particular dancing girl from Shiraz, as it turns out, had obviously captured the heart of this king, the painting of whom you saw. Yes, what's his name? His name is, and I shall have to sort of say it, but no tittering please in the audience, is Fat Ali Shah. Now, not that that describes his look, as Tom will verify having seen the painting.
这种影响其实相当微乎其微，因为这位国王有，哦，我想大约有1,000个妾室。但有趣的是，人们注意到，这位来自设拉子的特定舞女，显然俘获了这位国王的心，你刚才看到了他的画像。是的，他叫什么名字？他的名字是——我得好好说一下，但请观众朋友们千万不要嗤笑——法特·阿里·沙（Fath-Ali Shah）。当然，这并不是在形容他的外貌，正如汤姆看过画像后所能作证的那样。
And he had very sporting high heels, I have to say. He heels I have to say he had the most enormous beard didn't he this is we as the sign of virility so Ali and I went yesterday to the exhibition on epic Iran at the Victorian Albert Museum and if you haven't seen it it's really wonderful and this guy fat Ali Shah he was not particularly fat but he does the most enormous beard. And I'm guessing that a large beard is a symbol that you can cope with a thousand confidants. He had a... I mean, interestingly, your previous podcast was on eunuchs because his uncle was a eunuch.
而且我必须说，他穿着非常时髦的高跟鞋。鞋子，我必须说，他有着最庞大的胡须，不是吗？这是我们作为男子气概的象征。所以阿里和我昨天去了维多利亚和阿尔伯特博物馆（Victoria and Albert Museum）的“史诗般的伊朗”（Epic Iran）展览，如果你还没看过，它真的很棒。而这位法特·阿里·沙，他并不是特别胖，但他留着最硕大无比的胡须。
Sadly, yes, castrated at the tender age of six in order to prevent him actually becoming king. But that didn't stop him. And because he couldn't obviously have any children, his nephew decided to really go for it and basically created an entire tribe on his own. He's quite a character, this chap. But what's interesting about the nightingale,
我猜，巨大的胡须象征着你能够应付一千个知己。他有一个……有趣的是，你之前的播客是关于太监的，因为他的叔叔就是一个太监。可悲的是，是的，在六岁时就被阉割了，以防止他真正成为国王。但这并没有阻止他。而且因为他显然不能有任何孩子，他的侄子决定放手一搏，基本上靠一己之力创造了一个庞大的家族。这家伙真是个奇人。但关于夜莺，
whose name in Persian actually is Tuti, which, as Tom and I were discussing earlier, actually means parrot, which is not quite as attractive a name. But the term in Persian, I suppose, is a little bit more... It was meant to be a little bit more dismissive. I prefer Nightingale because I think Nightingale sounds nicer. So what influence did she exert?
有趣的是，她在波斯语中的名字其实是“图蒂”（Tuti），正如汤姆和我之前讨论过的，其实意思是“鹦鹉”，这名字可没那么迷人。但在波斯语中，这个词，我想，稍微有点……它原本带有一点轻蔑的意味。我更喜欢“夜莺”，因为我觉得夜莺听起来更好听。那么她施加了什么影响呢？
The only influence really that I could find that she exerted is one is that she came to the notice of British observers at the time who said that she clearly had captured the heart of the king, which, let's face it, if you have 1,000 concubines and it's the one that captured the heart, that's not bad. And she died very young, tragically, and the king was very moved by this and was seen to visit her grave regularly with melancholia.
我能找到她施加的唯一影响是，她引起了当时英国观察员的注意，他们说她显然俘获了国王的心。让我们面对现实吧，如果你有一千个妾室，而她是那个俘获了你心的女人，那已经相当不错了。她很年轻就不幸去世了，国王对此非常感动，并且被看到经常带着忧郁去她的坟墓探望。
And actually what they said was that this young girl basically humanised this king. So she had a modest influence. I can't say it's big and I have to say... Is that it? I have to say, if I wasn't here, I don't think she'd get into the top ten. I thought the least she would have encouraged him
事实上，人们说这个年轻女孩基本上人性化了这位国王。所以她有着 modest 的影响。我不能说它很大，而且我必须说……这就完了？我必须说，如果我不在场，我觉得她根本进不了前十名。我以为她至少会鼓励他
to invade India or something. No, no, he was far too busy in the harrow. I mean, a thousand concubines. Is there time for anything else? OK, so... So that, I'm afraid... She didn't do anything. She died young and she was called the parrot.
去入侵印度什么的。不，不，他在后宫里忙得不可开交呢。我是说，一千个妾室，还有时间做别的吗？好吧，所以……所以，恐怕……她什么也没做。她很年轻就死了，还被称为鹦鹉。
But she was, yeah, but... But she was Persian. But she was noticed. She was noticed by the British and she was Persian. And I suppose she does reflect, and it allows us to talk a little bit about this, I suppose, is the fact that, yes, in these societies where you had, what can we say, you can have four wives and as many concubines as you can afford,
但她确实是，是的，但是……但她是波斯人。但她被注意到了。她被英国人注意到了，而且她是波斯人。我想这确实反映了——这也让我们能够稍微谈谈这一点——这样一个事实，即在这些社会里，正如我们所说，你可以有四个妻子以及你能负担得起的任意数量的妾室，
I mean, mistresses don't really come into it. Okay, so you can see, ladies and gentlemen, why the nightingale or the parrot was at number ten. That's right. So that's her. So number nine, you said that the parrot had, or nightingale, had... Let's go for nightingale, I think. Had no influence on history. Our next one is someone who had an absolutely outsized influence on history.
我的意思是，情妇在这个体系里其实并不算什么。好吧，所以女士们先生们，你们可以看到为什么“夜莺”或“鹦鹉”能排在第十位。就是这样。这就是她。那么排在第九位的是，你刚才说鹦鹉或者夜莺，有……我们还是叫她夜莺吧。对历史没有任何影响。我们的下一个人物，是一个对历史产生了绝对巨大影响的人。
And you may well be surprised to discover she's only at nine. Yeah. Cleopatra, in at number nine, of course, is one of the great names, not just in ancient history, but in global history. Absolute kind of historical celebrity. The mistress of the two most powerful men in the world, first Julius Caesar and then Mark Antony. And you may be wondering, well, why is she so low? Well, the answer is that by our rubric,
你可能会惊讶地发现她只排在第九位。是的。克莉奥帕特拉（Cleopatra），排名第九，当然是古代史乃至全球历史上最响亮的名字之一。绝对是某种历史名流。世界上最有权势的两个男人的情妇，先是尤利乌斯·恺撒（Julius Caesar），然后是马克·安东尼（Mark Antony）。你可能会想，为什么她排得这么靠后？好吧，答案是根据我们的标准，
you have to come from nowhere and achieve great things. Cleopatra is the queen of Egypt. She, of course, is not as powerful as the Roman warlords who control the day because middle of the first century BC Rome is the superpower and Egypt is pretty much the only independent kingdom left after several centuries of Roman conquests across the Mediterranean. But Cleopatra is a player. And so she is bringing things that both Caesar and Antony want. And I think it's absolutely telling that the reputation of Cleopatra among the Romans and then kind of more recent works of pornography, for instance, have been obsessed by her, is that she had a voracious sexual appetite.
你必须出身于微末却成就了大业。克莉奥帕特拉是埃及女王。她当然不如那些掌控时局的罗马军阀那么有权势，因为公元前一世纪中叶，罗马是超级大国，而埃及在地中海经过几个世纪的罗马征服后，几乎成了唯一幸存的独立王国。但克莉奥帕特拉是一个玩家。所以她带来了恺撒和安东尼都想要的东西。我认为这绝对能说明问题：克莉奥帕特拉在罗马人以及后来的色情作品（例如）中的名声，一直痴迷于她拥有惊人的性欲。
And this is kind of explains her relentless appetite. In fact, as far as we know, she only ever slept with two men. And these two men both happen to be incredibly powerful. And I think that that tells you what she was about. She slept with first Julius Caesar and then with Mark Antony because she needed Roman power. First of all, with Caesar to establish her on the Egyptian throne. So she came from a long line of Macedonian kings and queens
这某种程度上解释了她那不知疲倦的胃口。事实上，据我们所知，她一生只和两个男人睡过。而这两个男人恰巧都拥有不可思议的权势。我认为这说明了她究竟是个什么样的人。她先是和尤利乌斯·恺撒睡觉，然后又和马克·安东尼睡觉，因为她需要罗马的力量。首先，她需要恺撒来确立她在埃及王位的地位。所以她出身于一长串马其顿国王和女王的血脉，
who had adopted the native Egyptian tradition of brother and sister marrying each other and Cleopatra was initially married to her younger brother Ptolemy the 13th but she didn't want him around kind of pesky younger brother so she gets embroiled in the civil war in Alexandria Caesar turns up Cleopatra according to the story, has herself delivered to Caesar, rolled up in a carpet. That's right. And I think that Cleopatra, if that's true, has judged Caesar's character. But the interesting thing about her, I suppose,
他们采纳了埃及本土兄妹结婚的传统，克莉奥帕特拉最初嫁给了她年幼的弟弟托勒密十三世（Ptolemy XIII），但她不希望这个烦人的小弟弟在身边，于是她卷入了亚历山大港的内战。恺撒出现了，根据传说，克莉奥帕特拉把自己裹在地毯里送到了恺撒面前。没错。我想克莉奥帕特拉如果这是真的，她对恺撒性格的判断是非常准确的。但关于她，最有趣的地方，我想，
is where the balance of power is, really. Because certainly with Mark Antony, I think she's very much got the whip hand, hasn't she? Well, she gets it. I mean, certainly with Caesar, it's evident. She's kind of the classic paradigm of the mistress, someone who is very kind of dependent on Caesar. But then once, you know, once Caesar's established her securely on the throne, she, you know, she becomes a player in her own right. Something of the sort of the outsider when
在于权力平衡究竟在哪里。因为对于马克·安东尼来说，我认为她绝对稳操胜券，不是吗？嗯，她确实掌控了。我的意思是，对于恺撒来说，这是显而易见的。她是情妇的经典范式，一个在很大程度上依赖于恺撒的人。但一旦恺撒把她稳固地扶上王位，她就……她自己也成了一个玩家。当她……
she, when the Romans don't really take to her, do they? Well, she goes to Rome just before the Ides of March and causes a great scandal. She snubs Cicero, you know, who's a kind of very offended by this. Yeah, never snub an academic. Never snub the academic. Yeah, no, that's true. And then the Ides of March happens, and Cleopatra's... Oh, and Cleopatra's got herself pregnant as well with Caesar.
当罗马人并不真正接受她时，她就像是个局外人，对吧？是的，她在三月节（Ides of March）前夕去了罗马，并引发了一场巨大的丑闻。她冷落了西塞罗（Cicero），你知道的，他对此感到非常被冒犯。是的，永远不要冷落学者。永远不要冷落学者。是的，没错。然后三月节就发生了，克莉奥帕特拉……哦，而且克莉奥帕特拉还怀上了恺撒的孩子。
Was she there over the Ides of March? Yes, she's there at the Ides of March, and she's her young son, Caesarian. Caesarian. Giving a clue as to who the father is. I know. So her plan, basically, to establish a kind of dynastic union with the most powerful man in Rome is foiled by Caesar's assassination.
她三月节的时候在那儿吗？是的，她在三月节时在那儿，她还带着她的小儿子恺撒里昂（Caesarian）。恺撒里昂（Caesarian）。这给谁是父亲提供了一点线索。我懂。所以她的计划，基本上是与罗马最有权势的人建立一种王朝联盟，却被恺撒的刺杀给破坏了。
And the Roman world gets divided between Mark Antony, Caesar's best lieutenant, and the future Augustus, Octavian, who is his adopted son. The world gets split. Mark Antony takes the eastern half of the Roman Empire and summons Cleopatra in a very imperious way to Tarsus, where he's made his base. And Cleopatra, who had wowed Caesar by being rolled up on the carpet, wows Antony, who's a much more vulgar man, by turning up with the most incredible bling. It's a massive kind of barge. This is the thing that, you know, Shakespeare makes kind of wonderful,
罗马世界随后被马克·安东尼（恺撒最得力的副将）和未来的奥古斯都、屋大维（他的养子）瓜分了。世界被分裂了。马克·安东尼拿走了罗马帝国的东半部分，并以一种非常傲慢的方式将克莉奥帕特拉召集到他建立基地的塔尔苏斯（Tarsus）。而克莉奥帕特拉曾经通过把自己裹在地毯里来惊艳恺撒，这次她带着令人难以置信的奢华珠宝出现，惊艳了一个粗俗得多的安东尼。这是一艘巨大的驳船。这就是莎士比亚写成的那种美妙的、华丽篇章的东西。
kind of purple passage. Presumably Mark Antony was quite taken by the fact that he would be going with Caesar's mistress. That's absolutely part of it, yes. But essentially Cleopatra is... She can play on that, of course. She is wowing him with her, you him with her gold, her splendour, her pizzazz. And basically... Could you say she emasculates him?
大概马克·安东尼对能和恺撒的情妇在一起这件事感到相当着迷吧？这绝对是其中一部分，是的。但本质上克莉奥帕特拉是……她当然可以利用这一点。她用她的黄金、她的辉煌、她的活力来征服他。基本上……你会说她阉割了他吗？
No, because Antony and Cleopatra are definitely a pair, a unit. But politically emasculates them. Well, that's what subsequently happens because Antony has an affair with Cleopatra, then goes back, basically signs a peace treaty with Octavian, by the terms of which he will marry Octavian's sister Octavia, who is a kind of upright Roman matron, very much not Cleopatra.
不，因为安东尼和克莉奥帕特拉绝对是一对，是一个整体。但在政治上阉割了他们。嗯，随之发生的就是这样，因为安东尼和克莉奥帕特拉有染，然后回去，基本上和屋大维签了一份和平条约，根据条约条款，他将娶屋大维的妹妹屋大维娅（Octavia），她是一个循规蹈矩的罗马贵妇，绝不是克莉奥帕特拉。
Antony stays with her for a while, but then basically bins her and shacks up with Cleopatra. Anthony stays with her for a while, but then basically bins her and shacks up with Cleopatra. And the propaganda in Rome coming from the future Augustus, which then gets picked up by Roman historians and in due course by Shakespeare and Cecil B. DeMille and Elizabeth Taylor and so on, is that this is all for love. But the probability is that it's a kind of dynastic throw. Antony is looking essentially to get rid of his pesky partner in the rule of the Roman world. He needs Cleopatra for that.
安东尼和她呆了一段时间，但随后基本上甩了她，和克莉奥帕特拉同居了。安东尼和她呆了一段时间，但随后基本上甩了她，和克莉奥帕特拉同居了。来自未来的奥古斯都的罗马宣传，随后被罗马历史学家以及后来的莎士比亚、塞西尔·B·德米尔（Cecil B. DeMille）、伊丽莎白·泰勒（Elizabeth Taylor）等人所采纳，宣称这一切都是为了爱情。但很有可能这是一种王朝的博弈。安东尼基本上是想摆脱他在统治罗马世界时那个讨厌的伙伴。为此他需要克莉奥帕特拉。
But it all goes wrong. Antony and Cleopatra get defeated at Actium. And by that point, basically, Cleopatra's the powerful one because Cleopatra's the queen of Egypt, but Antony's lost everything. Antony's nothing. So Antony dies, and the story is that Cleopatra
但一切都搞砸了。安东尼和克莉奥帕特拉在亚克兴战役（Actium）中战败。到了那个地步，基本上，克莉奥帕特拉才是掌权者，因为克莉奥帕特拉是埃及女王，而安东尼失去了一切。安东尼什么都不是了。所以安东尼死了，传说克莉奥帕特拉
then makes a pitch at Octavian. That wouldn't have gone down well, though. Well, Octavian doesn't need her, though. I must admit, I thought the sibling marrying stuff was all Zoroastrian, but you're saying the Egyptians are up to it as well, which is quite interesting. And they got their first wedding.
随后试图拉拢屋大维。不过那可不会顺利吧。嗯，不过屋大维并不需要她。我必须承认，我以为兄妹结婚的事情全是祆教（Zoroastrian）的习俗，但你是说埃及人也这么干，这挺有趣的。而且他们是第一场婚礼。
I'm going to try and get something Persian in on everyone. No, the Egyptians got their first. Did they? Yeah, I'm afraid so. Terrible. Not that that's the finest achievement. But anyway, that's me. So basically, and then Cleopatra, of course,
我试着在每个人身上都扯点波斯的东西出来。不，埃及人捷足先登了。是吗？是的，恐怕是的。太可怕了。这倒算不上什么最高成就。不过总之，那就是我。所以基本上，然后克莉奥帕特拉，当然，
famously commits suicide rather than walk in Caesar's trial with the asp smuggled in in the basket of figs. And by that point, you could almost say that the roles have reversed. And it's, you know, Cleopatra is the powerful one and Antony is the suitor. And so that then opens up a question which is focused by our next one. Which is interesting. Which is the question, can there be a male mistress? That's right.
极其出名地选择了自杀，而不是带着藏在无花果篮子里的毒蛇去游行示威、在恺撒的凯旋仪式上受辱。到了那个地步，你几乎可以说角色已经倒转了。然后，你知道的，克莉奥帕特拉才是那个有权势的人，而安东尼成了追求者。这就引出了一个由我们的下一个人物所聚焦的问题。这很有趣。也就是这个问题：有没有可能存在男性情妇？没错。
So, Ali, do you want to? Well, this takes me back to my medieval history. So who is number eight? So Piers Gaveston, who was the, shall we call it, the intimate friend of Edward II. And as I understand, was actually introduced into the household by his father, Edward Longshanks, which is probably not the wisest thing to have done,
所以，阿里，你想……嗯，这把我的思绪带回了我的中世纪历史。那么第八位是谁？皮尔斯·加维斯顿（Piers Gaveston），我们可以称之为爱德华二世（Edward II）的密友。据我所了解，他实际上是被他的父亲“长腿”爱德华（Edward Longshanks）引入宫廷的，这可能不是最明智的做法，
because he then discovered that the relationship between his son and Piers Gaveston was getting a little bit too close. Now, of course, we don't know posthumously. They've talked about how intimate that relationship was, but clearly he had a degree of influence which the nobility in England after Edward became king weren't particularly keen on. So there's a sort of an interesting dynamic there
因为他随后发现他的儿子和皮尔斯·加维斯顿之间的关系变得过于亲密了。当然，我们死后并不知道。人们一直在谈论这种关系有多亲密，但很明显，他拥有某种程度的影响力，而爱德华成为国王后，英格兰的贵族们对此并不是特别热衷。所以这里存在一种有趣的动态，
about whether we can categorise Piers Gaveston as a sort of a mistress type figure. Well, he's a favourite, isn't he? He's a favourite, yeah. So men who come from nowhere, or, you know, not even from nowhere, I mean, you know, Gaveston is... Came from Gascony. Yeah, he's from Gas from nowhere, I mean, Gaveston is... Came from Gascony. Yeah, he's from Gascony. I mean, he's kind of well-born.
关于我们是否可以将皮尔斯·加维斯顿归类为某种情妇类型的人物。嗯，他是个宠臣，不是吗？他是个宠臣，是的。所以那些出身微末，或者，你知道的，甚至不是出身微末的人——我的意思是，加维斯顿是……来自加斯科涅（Gascony）。是的，他是加斯科涅人。我的意思是，他出身相当高贵。
But the idea of the favourite who is over-promoted is a very distinctive category. But I think that what makes Gaveston kind of interesting is that, as you say, there is absolutely these kind of... There do seem to have been these rumours that there were kind of a sexual dimension to it. that gets picked up by by Christopher Marlowe who writes a play about it and it it's fed it into I think the Piers Gaveston Club at Oxford is the Bullingdon Club yes for kind of people who wear opera
但这种被过度提拔的宠臣概念是一个非常独特的类别。但我认为让加维斯顿变得有点意思的是，正如你所说，绝对存在这些……似乎确实存在某种性方面的传闻。这被克里斯托弗·马洛（Christopher Marlowe）捕捉到并写成了一部戏剧，它还喂养了牛津大学的皮尔斯·加维斯顿俱乐部（Piers Gaveston Club）——也就是布灵顿俱乐部（Bullingdon Club）的对口——专为那些穿着歌剧服装的人设立的。
clothes so anyway it does bring in this... I mean, it is an interesting sort of relationship. I mean, whether, you know, we were talking about, you know, later monarchs such as Catherine the Great, who had a string of sort of male lovers who played a very sort of influential role in her. I mean, actually helped her kill her husband, actually. But I guess they'd be favourites.
无论如何，这确实引入了这种……我的意思是，这是一种有趣的伴侣关系。我的意思是，无论我们谈论的是……你知道的，后来的君主，比如叶卡捷琳娜大帝（Catherine the Great），她有一串男情人，他们在她身上扮演了非常具有影响力的角色。我的意思是，实际上还帮她杀了自己的丈夫。但我想他们会是宠臣。
I mean, they were kind of favourites, yeah, but they were sort of... And I think Gaveston is a sort of a quite a... At least a famous one of these in that sense. Because I think that... I mean, the reason that Gaveston causes so much trouble, it seems from the sources, isn't really because of the sexual dimension, if indeed that existed.
我的意思是，他们某种程度上是宠臣，是的，但他们某种程度上是……而且我认为加维斯顿在这方面是一个相当……至少是其中一个著名的例子。因为我认为……我的意思是，加维斯顿引起这么多麻烦的原因，从史料来看，似乎并不是真的因为性层面的维度，如果这个维度确实存在的话。
It is because he's clearly a massive lad. He's really he's really he's really good at tournaments and he's so he's on campaign with Edward the first in Scotland and he bunks off to go to a tournament which is you know not that kind of interesting thing is if Edward the first has introduced him he must have thought highly of him I mean that's the thing he regrets it he does regret and then and then the moment the moment Edward dies, the now Edward II, the lavishing gifts on him is,
而是因为他显然是个大显眼包。他真的很擅长比武竞技。所以他跟随“长腿”爱德华在苏格兰参加战役，却翘了差事去参加比武竞技，你知道，这不是那种……有趣的是，如果“长腿”爱德华把他引入宫廷，他一定对他的评价很高，我是说，就是这样，他后悔了。他确实后悔了。然后，然后就在爱德华去世的那一刻，现在的爱德华二世开始向他挥霍大量礼物，
he makes him the Earl of Cornwall, and Gaveston enters the tournament again and kind of humiliates the established aristocracy. So I think it's that that really... He's a bit of a show-off, really. He's a kind of peacock. He's driven up with his Lamborghini and stuff like that. Absolutely.
封他为康沃尔伯爵（Earl of Cornwall），加维斯顿再次参加比武竞技，并某种程度上羞辱了老牌贵族。所以我认为真正原因在于此……他有点爱出风头。他就像是一只孔雀。他开着兰博基尼招摇过市之类的那种人。绝对是的。
He looks, and the traditional aristocracy aren't very keen on this sort of thing. So the aristocracy are kind of endlessly trying to get rid of him. And Edward is kind of forced to send him into exile. And then Gaveston comes back, and then the cycle goes over and over and over. And then finally in 1312, Gaveston gets cornered and executed. And his head gets chopped off. end is not pretty, is it? I don't think. I mean, if I remember...
他看起来，而传统贵族对这种事情并不是很感冒。所以贵族们不断地试图除掉他。而爱德华被迫将他流放。接着加维斯顿又回来了，然后这个循环周而复始。最后在1312年，加维斯顿被逼入绝境并被处决。他的头被砍了下来。结局真是不怎么好看，不是吗？我不觉得。如果我没记...
No, his head gets chopped off. It's Edward II whose end is not pretty. But wasn't Piers Gaveston hung, drawn and quartered? No, I think he just got executed. Oh, just that one. I think he just had his head chopped off. Just head chopped off, it's all right. But Edward II had it rather, yeah.
不，他的头被砍下来了。结局不太好看的是爱德华二世，对吧？难道皮尔斯·加维斯顿不是被处以绞刑、剖腹并分尸吗？不，我想他只是被处决了。哦，只有那个。我想他只是被砍头了。仅仅被砍头，那还好。但爱德华二世的遭遇就比较……是的。
Well, everybody involved in this story... They claim. Terrible things are told of them. So all the stuff about Gaveston, the rumours, we don't know whether they're true or not. Edward II notoriously, he ends up getting deposed by his wife, Isabella, the she-wolf of France, and her lover.
好吧，这个故事里涉及的所有人……他们声称。关于他们的可怕事情都被传了出来。所以所有关于加维斯顿的传闻，我们不知道是真是假。爱德华二世臭名昭著的是，他最终被他的妻子——“法兰西母狼”伊莎贝拉（Isabella）和她的情夫废黜了。
And he gets put in Barkley Castle and terrible screams are heard. And the story is, of course, that he is killed by having a red-hot poker shoved up his anus. Perhaps to disguise what had happened, and perhaps as a kind of brutal joke about his relationship. Was it also because you mustn't shed royal blood?
他被关进了伯克利城堡（Berkeley Castle），人们听到了可怕的惨叫声。而传闻当然是，他被一根烧红的火钳插进肛门致死。也许是为了掩盖所发生的事情，也许是对他那段关系的一种残酷玩笑。是不是也因为你不能流淌皇室血脉？
Yeah, that as well. That's a very sort of like, you know, Middle Eastern idea. Possibly Persian. Yeah, possibly. blood yeah that that that as well it's a very sort of like so brother you know Middle Eastern interesting I was reading as I told you there was reading a one of the earliest histories of Britain written written actually by a Persian traveler who who accounts for this actually describes the death of Edward the second in some. He finds it quite interesting. What did he say? What did he just say? He had something stuck up an orifice. And does he not elaborate? Yeah, he just says, you know, that was just the way it was. I think these were sort of routine means of execution.
是的，这也是其中之一。这非常类似于中东的想法。可能是波斯人的。是的，很可能是。血统，是的，那……也是，这非常类似于——所以兄弟，你知道的，中东的有趣之处在于，正如我告诉过你的，我当时正在读一本关于英国最早的历史书之一，实际上是由一个波斯旅行者写的，他在书中叙述了这一点，实际上描述了爱德华二世的死。他觉得这挺有趣的。他说什么了？他刚说了什么？他有什么东西卡在某个孔里了。他没有详细说明吗？是的，他只是说，你知道，事情就是这样。我认为这些都是常规的处刑方式。
These barbarians. These barbarian kings. Actually, interestingly, he also adds, which I'll throw in here, that the only reason Henry VIII had so many problems with his wives is he couldn't have more than one at the same time. I mean, if he could, like, you know, good Persian kings,
这些野蛮人。这些野蛮的国王。事实上，有趣的是，他还补充说——我在这里顺便提一句——亨利八世（Henry VIII）之所以有那么多关于妻子的麻烦，唯一的纯粹原因是他不能同时拥有一个以上的妻子。我的意思是，如果他能像优秀的波斯国王那样，
there'd be no problem. But his wife, Isabella, it was said of her that at the age of 70 she took an alchemical elixir that enabled her to have sex with 40 young men at a time. What, is she a wolf? Yes. We told you it was going to get a selection.
那就没问题了。但他的妻子伊莎贝拉，据说她在70岁时服用了某种炼金术灵药，使她能够同时与40名年轻男子发生性关系。什么，她是一只母狼吗？是的。我们告诉过你这会变得……
So shocking, shocking detail. But all I'm sure not true. So we only mention it to discount it, which is very much having your cake. I mean, that would be quite, yeah, 40, yeah. Having your cake and eating it. Yeah, having your cake, yeah, absolutely. So do we think, I mean,
太令人震惊了，令人震惊的细节。但肯定都不是真的。所以我们提到它只是为了反驳它，这简直就是鱼与熊掌兼得。我的意思是，那确实是，对的，40，对的。鱼与熊掌兼得。对的，鱼与熊掌兼得，绝对是。所以我们觉得，我的意思是，
Piers Gavison's kind of a mistress, isn't he? He is. I mean, I think we've got to be, you know, we've got to look at this, you know, with a level playing field, really. I mean, I think he definitely, you know, he uses his intimacy to gain influence. But it does, I mean, it does highlight the way in which, overwhelmingly, we are talking about societies
皮尔斯·加维斯顿算是一个情夫，对吧？他是。我的意思是，我认为我们必须，你知道的，我们必须以公平的竞争环境来看待这件事，真的。我的意思是，我认为他绝对，你知道的，他利用自己的亲密关系来获得影响力。但它确实，我的意思是，它确实凸显了这样一种方式，绝大多数情况下，我们谈论的是这样一个社会：
in which it's the men who have power. Yeah. And in a sense, therefore, for men to have, to obtain power through sexual relations yn y cyd-dynion sydd ganddo bwysigrwydd. Ie. Ac yn ymddygiad, felly, i fod i dynion gael bwysigrwydd drwy gysylltiadau seksuol, mae'n cael ei weld fel ddwylo. Ie. Ie, mae hynny'n wir. Yn ystod y cyd, rydych chi'n ymddygiad lle mae gennych unwyr. Ie. Mae hynny'n ein cyflwyno yn ôl i'r fesodd gyntaf.
在这个社会中，权力掌握在男性手中。是的。从某种意义上说，因此，男性通过性关系获得权力……是的。而且这种行为，因此，男性通过性关系获得重要地位，被视为是双重的。是的。是的，那是真的。在整个过程中，你处于一种拥有单一伴侣的行为中。是的。这把我们带回了第一点。
Felly, rwy'n credu bod Piers Gaveston, I mean he's kind of interesting choice and a good choice but I think doesn't deserve to feature any higher than number eight. So shall we move on to number seven? Number seven. Okay so number seven. There was a gentleman, I was coming on the tube here and he recognized me and said that he was coming here. So I don't know if you're here, gentlemen. Yes, there your hand goes up. Lovely to see you.
所以，我认为皮尔斯·加维斯顿，我的意思是，他是一个挺有趣的候选人，也是个不错的选择，但我认为他不配排在第八位之前。那么我们进入第七位吧？第七位。好的，那么第七位。有一位先生，我坐地铁来这儿的时候，他认出了我，并说他要来这儿。所以，我不知道你是否在这里，先生们。是的，你的手举起来了。很高兴见到你。
I'm so glad you made it. So he wasn't making it up. And I was, I never make anything up. No, no, no, absolutely. And I was busy reading a book, kind of swatting up, ready for this. And the book was a biography of Nelson, which will give you a clue as to the woman who comes in at number seven. Well, I have to say, she's a particular favourite of mine, but you, Karen. So Emma Hamilton, Lady Hamilton,
我很高兴你能来。所以他不是在瞎编。而我，我从来不瞎编。不，不，不，绝对没有。我当时正忙着读书，临时抱佛脚，为这个做准备。这本书是纳尔逊的传记，这会给你一个线索，让你猜猜排在第七位的是哪个女性。好吧，我得说，她是我特别喜欢的一个人，不过你，卡伦。所以，艾玛·汉密尔顿，汉密尔顿夫人，
who famously had an affair with, well, more than an affair, a great kind of lifelong, a great passion with Admiral Nelson. And I think that we can say of Emma Hamilton that she absolutely fits the paradigm of the woman who comes from nowhere...a'i ddefnyddio'n dda i'r paradigwyr o'r gwbl......y mae'n dod o gwbl... ...a'i ddefnyddio ar gyfer ei ddysgu sexu... ...i'w ddysgu'r sgwrs... ...i'w ddysgu'r ddysgu... ...i fyny'n fawr o'r sefydliad y mae hi wedi'i ddod o'i ffwrdd.
她最著名的事迹是与纳尔逊海军上将有过一段风流韵事，或者说不仅仅是风流韵事，而是一种伟大的一生挚爱、一种巨大的激情。我想我们可以这样评价艾玛·汉密尔顿：她绝对符合这样一个女性的范例：她出身于社会底层……并将其很好地运用到各种范例中……她来自底层……并将其用于她的性教育……以教授对话……教授学习……从她出身的机构中大大提升。
Yn 1765, pan oedd hi'n dod o'i ffwrdd... ...mae Lloegr yn cymdeithas cyffredinol. Mae Emma wedi'i ddod o' society and Emma is born in Cheshire, quite humble background, but she heads to London as so many ambitious people, both male and female, did. And London, of course, is a terribly dangerous, threatening place for young people with high ambitions. So Emma was always kind of treading a tightrope of potential ruin. And for women particularly, those who are going to use their sex appeal, the risk is always that you kind of end up pregnant, ruined, and just thrown on the dung heap.
1765年，当她出身时……英国是一个普遍的社会。艾玛出生在柴郡，背景相当卑微，但她像许多雄心勃勃的男女一样前往伦敦。当然，对于有着宏大抱负的年轻人来说，伦敦是一个极其危险、充满威胁的地方。所以艾玛总是如履薄冰，面临着潜在的毁灭。尤其是对于女性来说，那些想要利用自己性感特质的人，风险总是以怀孕、毁灭并被当成垃圾扔掉而告终。
So Emma is taking huge huge huge risks in going to London she she enters the kind of the theatrical world again as as so many successful mistresses Doug yeah so she works as as an actress she also she works as she's employed as a maid to successful actresses so she kind of picks up on that um and she becomes a dancer and her ability to i mean they have dancers in persia that's right yeah she was very so almost famous for her beauty of course i mean the thing with emma emma the thing with emma alton is it's just for me the most is the tragedy of it all actually i mean to be honest i mean she's basically passed on from one successful man to
所以艾玛去伦敦冒了巨大的、巨大的、巨大的风险，她进入了戏剧界，就像许多成功的情妇一样，对吧，是的，所以她作为女演员工作，她还工作，她受雇于成功女演员担任女佣，所以她从中学到了一些东西，嗯，她成为了一名舞者，她有能力，我的意思是波斯也有舞者，没错，是的，她几乎因美貌而闻名，当然，我的意思是，关于艾玛，关于艾玛·奥尔顿，对我和所有人来说，这一切最悲惨的地方在于，说实话，我的意思是，她基本上是从一个成功的男人转手给另一个
another so so so so you you yes so the first one so her achievement is to to bag a man yeah a powerful posh man and this man is charles greville who seems to be rather boring he was but much older is very rich yeah so so charles greville, it's kind of my fair lady scenario. So he puts her up in a house in Paddington and Emma is very, very... She shows herself to be very proficient at languages. So she learns Italian and French very quickly. She becomes great friends with the Queen.
另一个，所以所以所以所以你你是的，所以第一个，所以她的成就是钓到一个男人，对，一个强大且显赫的男人，这个男人就是查尔斯·格雷维尔，他看起来挺无聊的，他是的，但年长得多，非常有钱，对，所以查尔斯·格雷维尔，这有点像《窈窕淑女》的桥段。所以他在帕丁顿给她租了一栋房子，艾玛非常、非常……她表现出极强的语言天赋。所以她很快就学会了意大利语和法语。她和王后成了好朋友。
So... Of Naples. Yeah, the Queen of Naples. And she has this great thing, it's always my favourite thing about her, that she, and this is again where the dancing comes in, they're called Emma Hamilton's Attitudes. Oh, that's right, yes, yes, I read about it.
所以……那不勒斯的。是的，那不勒斯的王后。她有一件非常棒的事，这也是我最喜欢她的地方，就是她，这又回到了舞蹈的部分，它们被称为艾玛·汉密尔顿的姿势。哦，没错，是的，是的，我读到过。
And she kind of, she uses her control of dance and mime to simulate scenes from classical antiquity. So William Hamilton's pots, you know, there'll be nymphs or something on the pots. And she will pose. And, you know, before YouTube, this is the kind of hottest ticket in Naples. So everyone gathers round to watch her do her attitudes. And it's all, you know, it's all great fun. Very Enlightenment stuff, isn't it, really? Yes, yes.
她通过对舞蹈和哑剧的掌控，来模拟古代经典中的场景。所以威廉·汉密尔顿的花瓶，你知道的，花瓶上会有宁芙仙女之类的图案。然后她会摆出姿势。你知道的，在YouTube出现之前，这是那不勒斯最抢手的门票。所以大家都聚在一起看她摆姿势。而且，你知道的，这都挺有趣的。非常具有启蒙运动的风格，不是吗，真的？是的，是的。
And then, of course, Nelson turns up. Oh, yes. And he kind of turns up in the early 1790s, and, you know, eyes meet across crowded rooms. But then the thing that really kind of lights the taper is that Nelson turns up after the Battle of the Nile, where he has destroyed the French fleet. Napoleon's gone to Egypt to try and conquer Egypt, where he has destroyed the French fleet. Napoleon's gone
然后，当然，纳尔逊出现了。哦，是的。他在1790年代初出现，你知道的，人群拥挤的房间里四目相对。但真正点燃导火索的是，纳尔逊在尼罗河战役摧毁了法国舰队之后出现了。拿破仑去了埃及，试图征服埃及，在那里他摧毁了法国舰队。拿破仑去了
to Egypt to try and conquer Egypt, which he does, but gets stranded because Nelson has sailed in into the mouth of the Nile and with great daring has destroyed the French fleet. And as a result, he's absolutely the kind of, you know, the toast of the anti-French Europe and particularly of Britain, goes back to Naples, is informed that he's become Lord Nelson and he needs a rest. He needs to recharge his batteries. And Emma recharges his batteries for him. You put it so well.
埃及，试图征服埃及，他成功了，但却被困住了，因为纳尔逊乘船驶入尼罗河口，以无比的胆识摧毁了法国舰队。因此，他绝对成为了反法欧洲、尤其是英国的大红人，回到被告知他已成为纳尔逊勋爵，需要休息。他需要恢复体力。而艾玛为他恢复了体力。你总结得真好。
Well, I have to say, yes, William Hamilton is quite, how should we say? He's quite mellow about it. He's quite mellow about it, yeah. He doesn't take it too badly, does he? I think he's a mellow guy. Yeah He's quite mellow about it, yeah. He doesn't take it too badly, does he? I mean, he's... I think he's a mellow guy. Yeah, yeah.
好吧，我得说，是的，威廉·汉密尔顿相当，我们该怎么说呢？他对此看得很开。他对此挺随和的，是的。他没有太往心里去，对吧？我觉得他是个随和的人。对，他对此挺随和的，是的。他没有太往心里去，对吧？我的意思是，他……我觉得他是个随和的人。对，对。
And there's definitely something there where it's definitely a passionate love affair, isn't it? Between... Yes, so they both... Yes, and Nelson, of course, and the reason that Emma is a mistress is that Nelson is married. He's married, yeah.
这里面绝对有一种充满激情的爱情，对吧？在……是的，所以他们俩……是的，而且纳尔逊，当然，艾玛之所以是情妇，是因为纳尔逊已经结婚了。他结婚了，是的。
To Fanny, who is back in kind of wet, dank, dreary Norfolk, with apologies to anyone from Norfolk. But it can't measure up to the sheer pizzazz and excitement of the court. And Emma with her attitudes and her general sense of fun. And Nelson just gets completely besotted. And in due course there's a kind of a revolution which Nelson helps to well it doesn't more than help I mean basically puts down and this becomes a cause of considerable
娶了范妮，她留在潮湿、阴冷、沉闷的诺福克，向所有诺福克人道歉。但那里根本无法比拟宫廷纯粹的活力和兴奋。艾玛以她的姿势和普遍的幽默感。纳尔逊彻底被迷住了。不久之后发生了一场革命，纳尔逊协助平息了这场革命，好吧，不仅仅是协助，我的意思是基本上平息了，这引发了相当大的
controversy back in England you know has it has he gone too far has he been too brutal with it but Nelson helps to put that down and then and then they all go back home to England because William Hamilton has been recalled. And so they go back across Europe via Vienna, where Hayden in Vienna gets obsessed by Emma, big fan, go back to England. And Nelson, of course, is the hero that England needs at this difficult time in the war against Napoleon. He's tremendously charismatic. He's the great hero who saved Britain.
争议，回到英国后，你知道的，他是不是做得太过了？他是不是太残忍了？但纳尔逊协助平息了叛乱，然后他们都回到了英国，因为威廉·汉密尔顿被召回了。于是他们经由维也纳穿过欧洲返回，在维也纳，海顿对艾玛着迷不已，成了她的超级粉丝，随后返回英国。在反对拿破仑的这场艰难战争中，纳尔逊当然是英国在这个困难时期所需要的英雄。他极具个人魅力。他是拯救英国的伟大英雄。
He has colour. He is, in every way, the kind of the pin-up. And he brings this baggage of celebrity because it's kind of absolute tabloid fodder because basically you know his wife his wife is distraught doesn't want to give him up without a fight nelson's obsessed with emma emma is still with william hamilton the whole thing is absolute kind of you know it's brilliant everybody's obsessed by it and writing it up and everywhere they go they're being followed.
他很有个性。在各方面，他都是那种海报偶像。他带来了名人带来的包袱，因为这绝对是小报的谈资，基本上你知道的，他的妻子心烦意乱，不想轻易放弃他，纳尔逊对艾玛着迷，艾玛依然和威廉·汉密尔顿在一起，整件事简直就像是，你知道的，太精彩了，每个人都为之着迷并进行报道，他们无论走到哪里都被跟踪。
So it's exactly like the tabloids. But I was surprised that this early stage, because I always thought this sort of more prudish attitude has come out later on with the Victorian era, that the idea of someone having a mistress would have been, I suppose George III never had mistresses, did he? So he probably didn't set the tone wasn't right, was it? Well, no, it is...
所以这完全就像小报新闻一样。但我很惊讶在这么早期的时候，因为我总觉得这种比较保守的态度是后来维多利亚时代才出现的，那种有人有情妇的想法，我猜乔治三世从来没有过情妇，对吧？所以他大概没有树立起那种风气，对不对？嗯，不对，其实……
Probably a little bit more Puritan than we might have thought. Well, no, I mean, it doesn't lose Nelson his popularity. In a way, it's kind of in harsh, is it? She gets it. She gets it quite tough. It's not exactly a... So Nelson ends up... You know, he leaves his wife. Hamilton dies.
可能比我们想象的还要稍微清教徒一些。好吧，不，我的意思是，这并没有让纳尔逊失去人气。某种程度上，这有点像……对吧？她承受了。她承受了相当严厉的对待。这绝不是一个……所以纳尔逊最终……你知道，他离开了他妻子。汉密尔顿去世了。
Nelson and Emma shack up together in a house in Merton next to the River Wandel. So I'm very keen on walking London's rivers and you walk the River Wandel and suddenly every pub, every street is named after Nelson
纳尔逊和爱玛同居在莫顿（Merton）旺代河（River Wandel）旁的一所房子里。所以我非常喜欢沿着伦敦的河流散步，当你走在旺代河畔，突然间每家酒吧、每条街道都是以纳尔逊命名的
and you know that you've reached the site of the long vanished house that he and Emma Hamilton lived in. every pub, every street is named after Nelson, and you know that you've reached the site of the long-vanished house that he and Emma Hamilton lived in. But interestingly, they're after Emma. Yeah, so, of course, and they have a daughter, Horatia. So she's giving a massive clue as to who the father is. I mean, it couldn't, you know... And Horatia looks exactly like Nelson.
你知道你已经到达了他和爱玛·汉密尔顿曾经居住过的那座早已消失的房子的遗址。每家酒吧、每条街道都是以纳尔逊命名的，你知道你已经到达了他和爱玛·汉密尔顿曾经居住过的那座早已消失的房子的遗址。但有趣的是，他们是冲着爱玛来的。是的，所以，当然，他们还有一个女儿，霍拉西亚（Horatia）。所以她给出了一个巨大的线索，暗示谁是父亲。我的意思是，这不可能，你知道……而且霍拉西亚长得跟纳尔逊一模一样。
Oh, dear. I mean, obviously, she has an arm and hasn't lost an eye, but apart from that, she looks very like Nelson. I mean, obviously he has an arm and he hasn't lost an eye, but far from that, she looks very like him. And then of course, Nelson Sails Off dies at Trafalgar. And as he's dying, he thinks of Emma and he says, you know, please look after Emma, make sure that Emma is cared for. And he misses Emma so much that it is that, it is said, that prompts him to ask Hardy to give him a kiss. Doesn't have Emma there, so Hardy will do, and then he dies. So you think he actually did say to Hardy, I thought it was kismet,
噢，天哪。我的意思是，很明显，她有一条手臂，而且没有失去一只眼睛，但除此之外，她长得真的很像纳尔逊。我的意思是，很明显他有一条手臂，他没有失去一只眼睛，但除此之外，他长得真的很像他。然后当然，纳尔逊扬帆起航，在特拉法加战役中牺牲了。当他濒死时，他想着爱玛，他说，你知道，请照顾好爱玛，确保爱玛得到照顾。他太想念爱玛了，据说，这促使他要求哈迪（Hardy）吻他一下。身边没有爱玛，所以哈迪也可以将就，然后他就死了。所以你觉得他真的对哈迪说过，我以为这就是命中注定，
I thought it was about destiny or something. Oh, the Persian thing again. Well, yeah, I thought it was, yeah. No, but the bad news is, of course, is that once Nelson dies, i think it's his brother isn't it who sort of inherits everything yes and his brother is a vicar is that right yes and uh rather how should we say you know not he doesn't approve let's put that way yes and then of course uh you know one of the things that i found very i mean it's quite tragic that you have this extraordinary funeral, obviously, state funeral for Nelson, held in St Paul's and everything, all sort of glorious, technicolour and everything.
我以为那是关于命运什么的。哦，又是波斯那套。好吧，是的，我以为那是，嗯。不，但坏消息是，当然，一旦纳尔逊死了，我想是他的弟弟继承了一切，对吧？是的，他的弟弟是个牧师，是吗？是的，而且呃，该怎么说呢，你知道，不，他并不赞同，咱们这么说吧。是的，然后当然，呃，你知道，我发现非常……我的意思是，这相当悲惨，你拥有这场非同寻常的葬礼，显然是纳尔逊的国葬，在圣保罗大教堂举行等等，一切都显得那么辉煌、五光十色什么的。
The one person who isn't invited is Emma. Yeah. And she's left outside, basically. Yeah. And from then on, she's effectively ostracised. And loses her money. Yeah. I mean, it is tragic.
唯一没有被邀请的人是爱玛。是的。而她基本上被冷落在了外面。是的。从那以后，她实际上就被流放了。并且失去了她的金钱。是的。我的意思是，这确实很悲惨。
Has to sell the house at Merton. Sell the house at Merton. Goes to debtors prison, gets freed by some of Nelson's friends but she kind of you know dies I think in Calais which is 1815. Yeah 1815, Calais is the place you know like Beau Brummel where ruined regency celebrities go to die and it and it's yeah and it's it's it's terrible and and people do feel guilty about it and actually I mean you talked about kind of Victorian morality but I think it's in the 1840s that that people feel so guilty about how she's been she'd been treated that that the government ends up settling money on Horatio's three children as a way of kind of making amends. So I think that Emma is a kind of, in a way,
不得不卖掉莫顿的房子。卖掉莫顿的房子。进了债务人监狱，在纳尔逊的一些朋友的帮助下获释，但她差不多，你知道，死在了加来（Calais），那是在1815年。是的，1815年，加来就是那种地方，就像博·布鲁梅尔（Beau Brummel）那样，破产的摄政时期名人去那里等死，而且，这真的是……这太可怕了，人们确实为此感到内疚，实际上，我的意思是，你之前谈到了维多利亚时期的道德观，但我觉得正是在19世纪40年代，人们对她受到的待遇感到如此内疚，以至于政府最终决定给霍拉西亚的三个孩子一笔钱，作为一种弥补的方式。所以我觉得爱玛算是一种，从某种意义上说，
she's kind of the paradigm of the kind of mistress that we're going to be looking at from now on. But she's at number seven because she doesn't really, you know, she has this wonderful kind of relationship with Nelson, but she doesn't bed you know she she she has this wonderful kind of relationship with nelson but she doesn't bed it down and and in a sense the the way that she's used her beauty and her notoriety to to to leverage herself up into a position of power and wealth it ends up chewing her up and of course that's something that that you know we see today with with the way that celebrities get treated. Yeah, it is, yeah. But our next one is also someone who came from nowhere,
她可以说是我们从今以后要探讨的那类情妇的典范。但她排在第七位，是因为她其实并不，你知道，她和纳尔逊有着这种美妙的关系，但她并没有把这段关系尘埃落定，从某种意义上说，她利用自己的美貌和声誉来提升自己至权力和财富顶峰的方式，最终害惨了她。当然，这也是我们今天在名人的遭遇中所能看到的情况。是的，确实是这样。但我们的下一位也是一个出身卑微的人，
got involved with the theatre, but was incredibly successful. So basically, Nell Gwynn is very successful because in many ways she causes the least problems for her lover in that since Charles the second obviously Charles the second famous or for numerous mistresses it has to be said one of which is it lady castle made whose Barbara Villiers particularly particularly difficult it might be said certainly to charge so he had amazing underwear and the peeps going through
涉足戏剧界，但取得了极其巨大的成功。所以基本上，内尔·格温（Nell Gwynn）非常成功，因为在很多方面，她给她的情人带来的麻烦最少，鉴于查理二世显然，查理二世以拥有众多情妇而闻名，必须指出的是，其中一个就是城堡梅因夫人（Lady Castlemaine），即芭芭拉·维利尔斯（Barbara Villiers），可以说是一个特别、特别难缠的人，对查理来说肯定如此，所以他有着惊人的内衣，佩皮斯（Pepys）穿过
Whitehall sees lady castle mains underwear and kind of rushes back home and then there's some asterisks in his diary but the but the interesting thing with nell gwynn i suppose is first of all where she comes from so she's from very so she's a you know an actress come fruit seller well i think even lower than i mean she she comes from a slum i mean there are kind of various stories about where so gwyn that perhaps she comes from wales but i think almost certainly she's born kind of in you know the stews of drury lane covent garden uh and and clearly there's the kind of you know the the very very strong whiff of prostitution around everything to do with her origins, her upbringing.
白金汉宫（Whitehall）看到了城堡梅因夫人的内衣，然后急忙赶回家，接着他的日记里出现了一些星号，但是，对于内尔·格温来说，有趣的地方，我想首先是她的出身。所以她来自非常，所以她是一个，你知道，既是演员又是水果商的小贩——哦，我觉得甚至更低——我的意思是，她出身于贫民窟。我的意思是，关于她的出身有各种各样的传说——所以格温也许来自威尔士，但我认为几乎可以肯定她出生在，你知道的，德鲁里巷（Drury Lane）和科芬园（Covent Garden）的贫民窟里，而且很显然，与她的出身、她的成长经历有关的一切都带着一种非常非常浓厚的卖淫气息。
Yeah. In the pre-modern sense. Yeah, and so she becomes an orange girl. That's the famous thing that everyone knows about Nell Gwynn, is that she sells oranges. And she's, what, kind of, I think, 14 or something? But isn't it seen, to Charles II's credit in some ways, that he's besotted or falls in love with someone who is so much salt of the earth?
是的。在前现代意义上。是的，所以她成了一个卖橘子的女孩。这是每个人都知道的关于内尔·格温的著名事情，那就是她卖橘子。她那时几岁，大概，呃，14岁左右吧？但这在某种程度上不正是查理二世的功劳吗？他居然迷恋上了一个如此接地气的人？
It's not aristocratic. There's no basis of, here she is, coming from basic... So in some ways it adds to its popularity, of course, doesn't it? Absolutely, yes. So she goes from being an orange girl, which basically means it's the equivalent of selling fruit pastels in the West End now. You're going around with your tray of...
这不是贵族阶层。没有任何基础说，瞧她，出身于底层……所以在某种程度上，这也增加了她的知名度，对吧？绝对是的。所以她从一个卖橘子的女孩做起，这基本上相当于现在在西区（West End）卖水果软糖。你拿着托盘到处走……
Are there people selling fruit pastels in the West End? It's a mystery of 17th century historiography. Yeah, yeah. And not just oranges, it's kind of lemons and fruit. But these are exotic fruit pastels. Exotic, yes, exactly, exactly. And then she's very... Well, again, peeps calls her pretty witty Nell she's she's pretty she's witty and it's evident to the the guys who basically employed her
西区真的有人卖水果软糖吗？这是17世纪史学的一个谜。是的，是的。不仅是橘子，还有柠檬和水果。但这些都是异国风味的水果软糖。异国风味，是的，完全正确，完全正确。然后她非常……嗯，还是那件，佩皮斯称她为“俏皮机智的内尔”。她很漂亮，也很机智，而且雇佣她的那些家伙们显然看出来了
in the theater that she's got the makings of a great comic actress and I think I mean it's kind of thinking who a modern equivalent would be, and I would guess it would be Barbara Windsor. Yeah, I'm wondering. She's smart, she's clever, she's funny, she's sexy, she's sort of the earth. People just kind of seem to love her. And she's sort of like... The impression you get is that she's, for Charles anyway,
在剧院里，她具备成为一名伟大的喜剧演员的潜质。我想，这有点像在想谁会是现代版的她，我猜大概会是芭芭拉·温莎（Barbara Windsor）。是的，我也在想。她很聪明，很灵巧，很有趣，很性感，而且很接地气。人们似乎就是很喜欢她。而且她有点像……给你的印象是，对查理来说，
she's sort of problem-free. She doesn't demand anything of him. In the way that others do. They're all demanding things of him. She doesn't. And at the end of the day, he does actually get, you know, he does in his will, say, you know, look after Nell and all this sort of thing.
她几乎是个没有麻烦的人。她对查理没有任何要求。就像其他人那样。她们都在对查理提出各种要求。她没有。而且到头来，他确实在遗嘱里写了，你知道，要照顾好内尔之类的话。
Absolutely. Well, so she comes in in 1668 as Lady Castlemaine, Barbara Villiers, is kind of starting to fade. Right. She overplayed her hand and she's ageing, which of course is an occupational hazard for a mistress. And it becomes known that Charles II is looking for a replacement.
绝对的。嗯，所以她在1668年出现，当时城堡梅因夫人芭芭拉·维利尔斯开始失宠了。没错。她把牌打砸了，而且她正在变老，这当然是情妇的一大职业风险。而且大家都知道查理二世正在寻找替代者。
So there are kind of various actresses. And supposedly, Nell Gwynne gives a rival actress a laxative. Oh, really? Just before a date with Charles II which kind of obviously is well it's that does that does it's it's a brilliant thing to do to get rid of a potential love rival um and and so and then and and then it all goes tremendously well but I mean Charles II I mean I think that that of all because of course you know if he where there's a mistress there's a guy who has a mistress I think Charles II is has the, I think that of all... Because, of course, where there's a mistress,
于是有各种各样的女演员。据传说，内尔·格温给一个竞争对手的女演员下了泻药。哦，真的吗？就在与查理二世约会之前，这显然……嗯，这确实管用，为了摆脱潜在的情敌，这绝对是个绝妙的主意。而且，然后一切都进展得异常顺利，但是查理二世——我的意思是，我觉得在所有人当中，因为当然，你知道，哪里有情妇，哪里就有一个有情妇的男人，我觉得查理二世拥有——我觉得在所有人当中……因为当然，哪里有情妇，
there's a guy who has a mistress. I think Charles II has the greatest array of mistresses of any English king. And Nell Gwynne's great rival is Louise de Kerouet, who is French and Catholic, and who Nell Gwynne nicknames Squintabella. Squintabella? So, again, that's very kind of Barbara Windsor. Oh, dear.
哪里就有一个有情妇的男人。我觉得查理二世拥有的情妇阵容是所有英国国王中最庞大的。而内尔·格温最大的竞争对手是路易丝·德·克罗埃（Louise de Kéroualle），她是法国人，也是天主教徒，内尔·格温给她起绰号叫“斜眼贝拉”（Squintabella）。斜眼贝拉？所以，这又非常像是芭芭拉·温莎的风格。噢，天哪。
You know, get out of my pub! There's a whole... You stuck-up French Catholic. And there is a thing that... Squintabella. So Nell Gwynn, as a kind of sort-of-the-earth, lovable Cockney Protestant, is much more popular with the London crowds
你知道，滚出我的酒吧！这里有一整套……你这个自命不凡的法国天主教徒。而且有一种情况是……“斜眼贝拉”。所以内尔·格温作为接地气的、讨人喜欢的伦敦东区（Cockney）新教徒，比那个自命不凡的法国天主教徒更受伦敦民众的欢迎。
than the stuck-up French Catholic. Yeah. And there's this famous story that Nell Gwynne is out on a carriage. The mob gets her. The mob think... Yeah, yeah. And she says that, you know, I'm the king's Protestant. I'm the Protestant whore.
比那个自命不凡的法国天主教徒更受欢迎。是的。有一个著名的故事说，内尔·格温坐着马车外出。暴民包围了她。暴民以为……对，对。然后她说，你知道的，我是国王的新教徒。我是那个新教荡妇。
That's right, yeah. So they all go, great, no problem. Because we forget, of course, the sectarian anxieties of the 17th century, I should say. Yes. So, you know, having a Catholic, yeah, having a Catholic mistress. And Charles himself is kind of, you know, he... He's leaning towards...
没错，是的。于是他们都说，太棒了，没问题。因为当然，我们忘记了17世纪的宗派焦虑，我应该这么说。是的。所以，你知道，有一个天主教徒，是的，有一个天主教情妇。而查理自己也有点，你知道，他……他倾向于……
Well, Charles II is leaning towards Catholicism and also is basically in the pocket of the French, of Louis XIV. Yeah, absolutely, Louis XIV. So, Louise is, you know, his aspirational mistress. Was she not placed there by Louis XIV? Yes. Yeah, yeah, there you go.
好吧，查理二世倾向于天主教，而且基本上受制于法国人，受制于路易十四。是的，绝对的，路易十四。所以，路易丝就是，你知道，他理想中的情妇。她难道不是路易十四安插在那里的吗？是的。对，对，就是这样。
Yes, yes. And then also you've got Francis Stuart, who famously doesn't become his mistress and therefore you know plays hard to get and so Charles is even more obsessed with her and she's the one who becomes the first model for Britannia so so Nell Gwynn up to this point you could say I mean what's the difference with with um with Emma Hamilton the difference is of course that Nell Gwynn doesn't, you know, everything goes fine. Yeah, she doesn't get, Charles II dies and she is looked after and she does her son become...
是的，是的。然后你还有弗朗西斯·斯图尔特（Frances Stuart），她以拒绝成为国王的情妇而闻名，因此拿腔作调，这让查理对她更加着迷，她后来成为了不列颠尼亚（Britannia）的第一位模特。所以内尔·格温到目前为止，你可以说——我的意思是，她和爱玛·汉密尔顿有什么区别？区别当然在于内尔·格温没有，你知道，一切都很顺利。是的，她没有像那样落魄，查理二世去世后她得到了照顾，并且她的儿子成为了……
Yeah, so she has two sons. Two sons. And the son, the kind of various stories about how this works. One is that Charles is kind of, you know, hanging out with Nell and the young boy, who's also called Charles, wanders in. And Nell Gwynne says, come here, you little bastard. And Charles II says, you can't call my son a little bastard. And Nell Gwynne says, yes, but that's what he is.
对，所以她有两个儿子。两个儿子。关于这事是怎么发生的，有各种各样的说法。其中一种说法是，查理当时正和内尔以及那个也被叫做查理的小男孩在一起，小男孩走了进来。内尔·格温说：“过来，你这个小杂种。”查理二世说：“你不能叫我儿子小杂种。”内尔·格温说：“是的，但他就是个杂种。”
Unless you give him a peerage. Nicely done. And the other story, which is even more improbable, is that she kind of dropped him, hung him out of a window and threatened to drop him unless Charles gave him a peerage. So he becomes, I think, the Earl of Burford and then the Duke of St Albans, Charles Beauclair. And the Beauclairs, I think the house in Windsor that they got given, they lived there until quite recently.
除非你封他一个贵族头衔。干得漂亮。另一个更加离谱的说法是，她把儿子悬挂在窗户外面，并威胁说如果不给儿子封个贵族爵位就把他扔下去。于是他成为了，我想是伯福德伯爵（Earl of Burford），然后是圣奥尔本斯公爵（Duke of St Albans），查理·博克莱尔（Charles Beauclerk）。而博克莱尔家族，我想他们在温莎获赠的那座房子，他们一直住到不久前。
And they're all kinds of members of the aristocracy to this day. The line isn't extinct then, it's still... No, they're all very, very proud to be descended from Nell Gwynne and, you know, from Charles. So, I think that that's, you know, she's a winner. No, I think she is.
时至今日，他们家族里还有各种各样的贵族成员。所以这个血脉并没有断绝，它依然……不，他们都为自己是内尔·格温和查理的后代而感到非常非常自豪。所以，我觉得，你知道，她是个人生赢家。不，我想她确实是。
I mean, if you compare, obviously, with Emma Hamilton, I mean, that's, she's done well. Yes, she does, she has done well. So, she's in at six. And then at number five... Yeah, this is your one, I think. Yes, so Lily Langtry is a fascinating...
我的意思是，如果跟爱玛·汉密尔顿相比的话，这说明她混得很好。是的，确实，她混得很好。所以，她排在第六位。接下来是第五位……是的，我觉得这是你的领域。是的，所以莉莉·兰特里（Lily Langtry）是一个迷人的……
She complements and contrasts with Nell Gwynn. So Nell Gwynn uses the stage to become the mistress of a member of the royal, you know, to become a king. Lily Langtry uses her affair with the Prince of Wales, the future Edward VII, to become an actress. And the reason we put her in at five is that Lily Langtry serves as a kind of prototype for possibly the two most famous mistresses of the 20th century, Marilyn and Camilla. And Lily Langtry is part of a kind of a trend in the 19th century for
她与内尔·格温相辅相成，又形成了鲜明的对比。内尔·格温利用舞台成为了皇室成员的情妇——你知道，成为了王后。而莉莉·兰特里则利用她与威尔士亲王（未来的爱德华七世）的风流韵事成为了一名演员。我们把她排在第五位的原因是，莉莉·兰特里可以说是20世纪最著名的两位情妇——玛丽莲（Marilyn）和卡米拉（Camilla）的某种雏形。莉莉·兰特里是19世纪的一种潮流的一部分，
kind of celebrity courtesans who sleep with incredibly a range of famous people. So there's Lola Montes, despite her name is is actually Irish yeah and she kind of pretends to be a Spanish dancer and she gets off with um she's a fascinating figure though I think I mean Lola Montes uh to be honest I would have had her instead of Lily Langtry but yes we we we we have agreed yes we have debated this and now is not the time but I would say something. Yes, so Lola Monta, as you correctly pointed out, she has affairs with Franz Liszt, with Alexandre Dumas,
那是一群与众多名人发生关系的知名交际花。比如罗拉·蒙特斯（Lola Montez），尽管名字听起来像，但其实是个爱尔兰人，是的，她假装自己是个西班牙舞者，然后她和……她其实是个非常迷人的人物，我的说实话，我觉得我宁愿选罗拉·蒙特斯来代替莉莉·兰特里，但是是的，我们，我们已经同意了，是的，我们讨论过了，现在不是说这个的时候，但我要说点什么。是的，所以罗拉·蒙特斯，正如你正确指出的那样，她曾与弗朗茨·李斯特（Franz Liszt）、亚历山大·大仲马（Alexandre Dumas）——《三个火枪手》的作者——以及巴伐利亚国王路德维希一世（Ludwig I of Bavaria）有过风流韵事。
who writes The Three Musketeers, and famously with Ludwig I of Bavaria. Yeah, that's the best one. Lola Monta thinks she's absolutely made it. She's in this car here, hanging out in Bavaria. And then 1848 turns up, the year of revolutions, and she gets to go to America. One other famous person she has an affair with, of course, is Flashman.
是的，那是最好的一段。罗拉·蒙特斯觉得她彻底成功了。她坐着豪华轿车，在巴伐利亚厮混。然后1848年革命之年爆发了，她只好逃往美洲。她有过风流韵事的另一个名人，当然是弗莱士曼（Flashman）。
That's right, and that's how I became acquainted with Lola Montez, I have to say, is Flashman. So there's Lola Montez, and then there's those of you who've listened to the episode that we did on statues. May remember, on Whitehall, there's a statue of Spencer Cavendish, the Duke of Devonshire. This guy I'd never heard of till Dominic told me who he was I mean the most extraordinary lingerie you've ever seen on the statue and Dominic revealed that he was most interesting because he had an affair with this woman Catherine Walters who was known as Skittles and Skittles
没错，我就是通过弗莱士曼了解到了罗拉·蒙特斯，我必须承认这一点。这就是罗拉·蒙特斯，然后对于听过我们制作的关于雕塑那一集的听众来说，你们可能还记得，在白金汉宫（Whitehall）有一尊德文郡公爵斯宾塞·卡文迪许（Spencer Cavendish）的雕塑。这个人在多米尼克告诉我他是谁之前，我甚至都没听说过。我的意思是，那是你在雕塑上见过最不可思议的紧身衣，多米尼克透露说他是最有趣的，因为他与一个名叫凯瑟琳·沃尔特斯（Catherine Walters）的女人有过风流韵事，她被称为“九柱戏”（Skittles），而“九柱戏”
was famous for riding in the tightest riding habit that any woman... Riding through Hyde Park. Yes, riding through Hyde Park and St James' Park in this incredibly tight riding habit. And so she had an affair with the Duke of Devonshire, but also with Napoleon III and with the Prince of Wales, the future Edward VII, who probably comes second to Charles II
因身穿所有女性中……骑着马穿过海德公园（Hyde Park）。是的，穿着极其紧身的骑马装骑马穿过海德公园和圣詹姆斯公园（St James' Park）而闻名。所以她不仅和德文郡公爵有染，还和拿破仑三世以及威尔士亲王（未来的爱德华七世）有染，后者作为皇家情妇的赞助人，在数量上大概仅次于查理二世。
as a royal sponsor of mistresses. But didn't he sort of, wasn't he also quite, I mean Edward VII, I mean in terms of l'entente cordiale, wasn't it sort of partly he was having, you know, a few of his flings were quite good for building relations. Well that's what he said. I mean he was, you know, it was important for him. That's what he told mummy.
但难道他不是那种，难道他没有——我是说爱德华七世，从“挚诚协定”（l'entente cordiale）的角度来看，难道不是部分因为他，你知道，他的几段风流韵事在建立关系方面相当有帮助吗？嗯，他是这么说的。我的意思是，他是，你知道的，这对他很重要。他是这么对妈咪说的。
He was doing a diplomatic service, yeah. I'm not sure about that. It's important for, it's important for him. That's what he told mummy. He was doing a diplomatic service, yeah. Yeah. I'm not sure about that. I'm not sure about that. It's important for Anton Cordial that I have a few... But, I mean, I think Lily Langtry
他在执行外交任务，是的。我对这一点持保留态度。这对他很重要，对他的意义重大。他是这么对妈咪说的。他在执行外交任务，是的。是的。我对这一点持保留态度。我对此并不确定。对挚诚协定来说，有几个……但是，我的意思是，我认为莉莉·兰特里
is Edward VII's most famous mistress. Yeah, famous, yeah. They had the fling long before he succeeded his mother, Queen Victoria. Lily Langtry, she came from Jersey. She was known as the Jersey Lily. Her husband, who gives her the name, I think it's Edward Langtry, he turns up in Jersey with a fabulous yacht.
是爱德华七世最著名的情妇。是的，很有名，是的。在他继承母亲维多利亚女王的王位很久之前，他们就有一腿。莉莉·兰特里来自泽西岛（Jersey）。她被称为“泽西百合”（Jersey Lily）。她的丈夫，也就是给她起这个名字的人，我想他叫爱德华·兰特里（Edward Langtry），带着一艘豪华游艇出现在泽西岛。
So Lily Langtry, who's the daughter of this clergyman, who's an absolute ladies' man, completely notorious, kind of falls into his arms with great gratitude and they sail off to London. Her father is a ladies' man? Is that what you said? Yeah, her father is this... I think he's the dean of... And he's a great ladies' man. He's a great ladies' man. Oh. Yes, yeah.
所以莉莉·兰特里，这个牧师的女儿——这是一个绝对的花花公子，声名狼藉——满怀感激地投入了他的怀抱，然后他们一起扬帆驶向伦敦。她的父亲是个花花公子？你是这么说的吗？是的，她的父亲是这个……我想他是……的院长。而且他是个绝佳的花花公子。他是个绝佳的花花公子。哦。是的，是的。
And when she's in London, she's incredibly beautiful. She gets taken up by kind of artists. She serves as a model for all kinds of painters. And that's how she ends up with the Prince of Wales. And she's with the Prince of Wales for three years, gets presented to Queen Victoria, unbelievably. I mean, it's kind of, you know, she's... What did she make of it?
当她来到伦敦时，她美得惊为天人。她受到了艺术家们的追捧。她成了各种画家的模特。这就是她最终和威尔士亲王在一起的方式。她和威尔士亲王在一起三年，难以置信的是，她被引见给了维多利亚女王。我的意思是，这真是，你知道，她……她对此作何感想？
Well, Lily Lantry's incredibly charming. And all mistresses, to be a mistress, it's not just enough to be gorgeous. You've got to be charming and witty and intelligent. Yeah, absolutely. And so they separate. Basically, you know, Prince of Wales moves on to Pastors New. But he's always very fond of Lily.
嗯，莉莉·兰特里极具魅力。所有的情妇要想成为情妇，仅仅美艳动人是不够的。你还得迷人、机智、聪慧。是的，绝对的。于是他们分开了。基本上，你知道，威尔士亲王转向了新天地（Pastors New）。但他对莉莉一直很有好感。
But the problem that Lily faces once the Prince of Wales has kind of moved on is that all her creditors immediately move in because they've been living beyond their means. and so Lily's stuck for things to do and so her great friend Oscar Wilde says well have you thought of going on the stage so it exactly reverses what happens with with with Nell Gwynn and she but she's a great success at this she becomes a you know she's a fabulously good and she goes to America. She's a great smash on the American stage.
但威尔士亲王离开后，莉莉面临的问题是，她所有的债主立刻蜂拥而至，因为他们一直过着量入为出的生活——哦不，是入不敷出的生活——所以莉莉陷入了不知所措的境地，于是她的好朋友王尔德（Oscar Wilde）说：“嗯，你有没有考虑过登台演戏？”这正好与内尔·格温的经历相反，她在舞台上取得了巨大的成功，成为了一名——你知道，她是个好得惊人的演员——并且她去了美国。她在美国的戏剧舞台上大获成功。
She starts to kind of take an interest in horse racing, starts to own horses. She wins Goodwood. She hangs out with Gladstone. I mean, obviously doesn't have an affair with Gladstone. They wouldn't have an affair with Gladstone. But she becomes incredibly famous. And she ends up marrying this guy,
她开始对赛马产生兴趣，并开始拥有自己的马匹。她赢得了古德伍德（Goodwood）赛马。她与格莱斯顿（Gladstone）交往。我的意思是，显然没有和格莱斯顿发生风流韵事。他们不可能和格莱斯顿有染。但她变得极其出名。最终她嫁给了一个人，
and I'm going to have to read this because his name is so posh, Hugo Gerald de Bath. I hope I've pronounced that right. Hugo Gerald de who? Hugo Gerald de Bath. Bath. And she ends up as Lady de Bath. And in her 70s, she lives in Monte Carlo.
我得读一下这个名字，因为他的名字太高大上了：雨果·杰拉德·德·巴斯（Hugo Gerald de Bath）。希望我没有发错音。雨果·杰拉德·德……谁？雨果·杰拉德·德·巴斯。巴斯。她最终成了德·巴斯夫人（Lady de Bath）。70多岁时，她住在蒙特卡洛（Monte Carlo）。
Gerald is in Venice. And it's all... So when did she eventually die? 1920s sometime. Oh, right. So she's a bridge between the age of the classic Victorian courtesan and, of course, the famous mistresses of the 20th century. So Marilyn, who's an actress, you know just as famous as JFK yeah and Camilla
杰拉德则在威尼斯。一切都是……那么她到底是什么时候去世的？20世纪20年代的某个时候。哦，对的。所以她是经典维多利亚时代交际花时代与20世纪著名情妇之间的一座桥梁。比如玛丽莲，她是一位女演员，你知道，和肯尼迪（JFK）一样出名，还有卡米拉，
who I think is actually descended from Lily Lantry so so anyway so so Lily Lantry I think is is is a deserved she deserves to be at number five she you know she makes a tremendous success of it. She still has pubs named after her to this day. Oh, and I forgot to say about Nell Gwynn. Nell Gwynn, I think, is the only mistress to have a statue. We're very interested in statues. There's a statue of Nell Gwynn.
我觉得她实际上是莉莉·兰特里的后代。所以无论如何，莉莉·兰特里我觉得是实至名归，她理应排在第五位，她（在事业上）取得了巨大的成功。时至今日，依然有以她名字命名的酒吧。哦，我忘了说内尔·格温了。内尔·格温，我想，是唯一一位拥有雕塑的情妇。我们对雕塑非常感兴趣。有一尊内尔·格温的雕塑。
She's the only royal mistress to have had a statue. There's a block of flats in Chelsea called Nell Gwynn House. And there's a statue of her? There's a statue of her, yeah. Wow. And I think, you know, in our statues episode we were... Oh yes, I've been past that. We were talking about how all the statues are kind of basically of generals, but we could
她是唯一一位拥有雕塑的皇家情妇。切尔西（Chelsea）有一栋名为“内尔·格温府”（Nell Gwynn House）的公寓楼。那里有一尊她的雕塑？是的，有一尊她的雕塑。哇。而且我想，你知道，在我们关于雕塑的那一集里，我们……哦，对的，我路过过那里。我们当时在讨论所有的雕塑基本上都是将军的雕塑，但我们要是能
do with more statues of royal mistresses. So a statue of Nell Gwynn, a statue of Lily Langtry, it would be great. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
多一些皇家情妇的雕塑就好了。所以，内尔·格温的雕塑，莉莉·兰特里的雕塑，那会很棒。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐而已》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
评论、八卦猛料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们有——在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外番外节目
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Number four. Now, this is a proper mistress. Yeah, we're talking proper mistress. Yeah, this is a proper mistress. Yeah, we're talking proper. Yeah, this is proper stuff. None of these sort of actresses.
以及提前购买现场门票的特权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。第四位。现在，这是一位真正的情妇。是的，我们在谈论真正的情妇。是的，这是一位真正的情妇。是的，我们在谈论真正的。是的，这是正经货色。可不是什么演员之流。
So, Madame de Pompadour, who is the mistress to Louis XV of France. Now, the interesting thing about Madame de Pompadour, as powerful as she becomes, and she actually does break some of the standards that we've been talking about in as much as in the French royal system there was a post of chief royal mistress.
那么，蓬巴杜夫人（Madame de Pompadour），法国国王路易十五的情妇。现在，关于蓬巴杜夫人的有趣之处在于，尽管她权力变得多么强大，她确实打破了我们一直在谈论的一些标准，因为在法国皇室体系中，曾设有首席皇家情妇这一职位。
Yes. And not only does she fill this post, but it comes with lodgings. Make prens on keep. Yeah. So this is a formal position for Louis V. And she ends up basically effectively running parts of the state, which is, you know, she has quite a lot of political power.
是的。她不仅填补了这个职位，而且还自带住所。包吃包住。是的。所以这是路易十五的一个正式职位。她最终基本上有效地管理着国家的部分地区，你知道，她拥有相当大的政治权力。
She becomes prime minister, basically. Yeah, she basically does. She also is there, as we were saying, long after, you know, you said, you know, age is a sort of an occupational hazard, but not in her case. I mean, she hangs in there. Yes. Until quite late, you know, and she knows that she gets to a stage where she sort of says,
她基本上成了首相。是的，她基本上就是。正如我们所说的那样，她一直在那里，你知道的，你曾说过年龄是某种职业风险，但在她身上并非如此。我的意思是，她坚持了下来。是的，直到很晚，你知道，她知道自己到了这样一个阶段，她甚至会说：
I'm not really interested in all this intimate stuff anymore. I can't handle it. So I'm going to bring in some other people to sort out the king on this basis, as long as they don't mess around with his affections. So it's kind of layers of mistress. Yeah. So she's in a different league, actually, I think. But kind of creepy and weird as well.
我对所有这些亲密的事情真的不再感兴趣了。我应付不来。所以我打算引进一些其他人来在这方面安抚国王，只要他们不干涉国王对她的钟爱就行。所以这是一种层层递进的情妇关系。是的。所以她其实处于一个不同的级别。但同时也让人觉得有点毛骨悚然和诡异。
She's sort of like a second wife. But it's interesting, because, I mean, when kind of creepy and weird as well. She sort of sounds like a second wife. But it's interesting, because when we go back, if we can go back to number ten, what's the distinction between this as a mistress and a second wife? Well, I'll tell you one distinction. I mean, she's basically his second wife, right? But one distinction is that she is groomed for that position. Groomed?
她有点像第二个妻子。但这很有趣，因为——当那种毛骨悚然和诡异的感觉再次袭来时。她听起来有点像第二个妻子。但有趣的是，当我们回过头来看——如果我们能回到第十位的话，作为情妇的这层身份与第二任妻子之间有什么区别？好吧，我来告诉你一个区别。我的意思是，她基本上就是他的第二任妻子，对吧？但一个区别是，她是为这个职位接受过专门培养的。培养？
She's groomed. And I use the word advisedly. So before she becomes Madame de Pompadour, her name is Poisson, so she's called Fish. Fish? Yes. It's almost as bad as Pat. Jean-Antoinette Poisson.
她是被精心培养的。我谨慎地使用了这个词。在成为蓬巴杜夫人之前，她姓泊松（Poisson），所以她被称为“鱼”。鱼？是的。这名字几乎跟帕特（Pat）一样糟。让-安托瓦内特·泊松（Jean-Antoinette Poisson）。
And at the age of nine, apparently she's told by a fortune teller that she's going to win the heart of a king. And so from that point on, she becomes known to her family as a reinet, little queen. And basically, her parents start grooming her to become the royal mistress, which, I mean, even for the French... LAUGHTER
据说她在九岁时，被一个算命先生告知她将赢得一位国王的芳心。所以从那时起，她的家人开始称呼她为“小女王”（reinet）。基本上，她的父母开始培养她成为皇家情妇，这意味着，即使对法国人来说……笑声
Yeah, I mean, I must admit, that's... It's quite odd, isn't it yeah so and so you know rather like Emma Hamilton kind of educates herself to you know be able to kind of hang out with with rich people she is you know she's she's kind of educated given dance lessons all that kind of stuff. I mean, you're saying it's sort of quite creepy in some ways. It's probably creepy to us, but probably not to 18th century French society. I mean, if you think that their idea is that this is a formal position.
是的，我的意思是，我必须承认，那……这挺奇怪的，不是吗？是的，所以……就像爱玛·汉密尔顿通过自学来让自己能够与富人交往一样，她（蓬巴杜夫人）也是——她接受过教育，上过舞蹈课，诸如此类的事情。我的意思是，你刚才说在某些方面这挺诡异的。对我们来说可能很诡异，但对18th世纪的法国社会来说可能并不。我的意思是，如果你考虑到他们的观念认为这是一个正式的职位的话。
Yeah, so she's applying for a job. So the king is out hunting and she goes along to the hunting and she wears a pink dress and drives a kind of blue chariot. And then she puts on a blue dress and drives a pink chariot while he's hunting. And you'd think rather than infuriating him, which frankly if I was hunting and this woman turns up kind of scaring all the game, I'd be pretty cross. But no, he really likes this.
是的，所以她在应聘一份工作。当时国王正在打猎，她就跟着去了打猎现场，穿着一件粉红色的裙子，驾着一辆蓝色的战车。然后她又换上一条蓝色的裙子，驾着一辆粉红色的战车，而国王正在打猎。你可能会觉得这会激怒他，坦白说，如果我在打猎，而这个女人突然出现把所有猎物都吓跑了，我会非常生气的。但并没有，他真的很喜欢这样。
And so then they have a masked bull at which he, very peculiarly, goes as a tree. Goes which he very peculiarly goes as a tree. He goes as a tree? He goes as a tree. Wow. And she goes as Diana, the goddess of hunting. So all very... Right.
于是他们举办了一个假面舞会，非常奇特的是，国王扮成了一棵树。非常奇特的是，他扮成了一棵树。他扮成了一棵树？他扮成了一棵树。哇。而她扮成了黛安娜（Diana），狩猎女神。所以这一切非常……对的。
Right. And so then they take off their masks. But you're beautiful. And there it is. She's kind of... But she, as you say, is absolutely qualified. I mean, she's an incredibly impressive woman, very, very competent,
没错。然后他们摘下了面具。但你很美。事情就这样成了。她有点……但正如你所说，她绝对是实至名归。我的意思是，她是一个令人印象深刻的女性，非常非常有能力，
and basically the king can't function without her. And when I say function, I mean politically. And here's the interesting thing, I suppose, in terms of where we're heading, is that she has a very, very emphatic and decisive political role to play because she's the one who basically in the seven years war manages the switch in alliance between in and makes yeah austria and france basically allied after years and years of
国王基本上离不开她。当我谈到“离不开”时，我是指在政治上。而这里有趣的地方，我想，就我们接下来的走向而言，在于她扮演了一个非常、非常明确且具有决定性的政治角色，因为她是那个在七年战争中基本主导了同盟转换的人，使得……是的，奥地利和法国在经历多年的敌对之后基本上结成了同盟，
animosity but the seven years war um as those of you who who've listened to the episode we did with dan snow um i mean it actually didn't go very well no not for the phrase so the famous as those of you who've listened to the episode we did with Dan Snow, it actually didn't go very well. No, not for the French. So the famous phrase, après moi, le deluge. Yeah, that's her, yes. Yeah, that's her famous phrase. But, yeah, she was obviously awesomely competent, efficient, also a great patron of the Enlightenment,
但七年战争——正如那些听过我们与丹·斯诺（Dan Snow）合作那一集的听众所知——我的意思是，结果其实并不怎么好。不，对法国人来说不是这样的。所以那句名言：“我死后哪怕洪水滔天”（après moi, le deluge）。是的，那是她的话，是的。是的，那是她的名言。但是，是的，她显然能力惊人、效率极高，同时也是启蒙运动的伟大赞助人，
a great enthusiast for Diderot But she sort of set up this house for his sort of sub-mistresses Yes He called it the stag house or something Yeah It's quite an extraordinary It's all very French
狄德罗（Diderot）的狂热崇拜者。但她为国王的那些次要情妇建立了一座房子，是的。她称之为“鹿苑”（stag house）还是什么的。这相当非同寻常。这一切都非常法兰西风格。
It's all very French Extremely powerful though Yes So I think she's in it for But we've now come to the top three Okay It's getting important now The top three
这一切都非常法兰西风格。不过权力确实极大。是的。所以我觉得她是实至名归……但我们现在来到了前三名。好的。现在开始变得重要了。前三名。
In at number three um we have a greek uh aspasia i'll have to leave this one to you and i well no ali because well there is going to be a person that i mentioned yes but i i i there's a case i think for having asp having Aspasia in at number one. So she is from Miletus, which is a famous trading city on the Aegean coast of what is now Turkey, had been destroyed by the Persians, but by the mid fifth century when Aspasia is born,
排名第三的是，嗯，我们有一位希腊人——阿斯帕西亚（Aspasia）。这个得交给你来评了，我——好吧，阿里，因为——嗯，其实会有一个人是我要提到的，是的，但我——我觉得有理由把阿斯帕西亚排在第一位。她来自米利都（Miletus），那是现在土耳其爱琴海沿岸一个著名的商业城市，曾被波斯人摧毁，但在公元前五世纪中期阿斯帕西亚出生时，
is starting to recover, it's likely that she is descended from a very aristocratic Athenian family to which the great Athenian statesman Pericles, who commissions the Parthenon and rebuilds Athens in its golden age. And so she goes with her sister to Athens and settles there. Now, Athens is a kind of very chauvinist place, so she's seen as a foreigner.
这座城市开始复苏，她很可能是一个非常高贵的雅典家族的后代，伟大的雅典政治家伯里克利（Pericles）——他委托建造了帕台农神庙并在黄金时代重建了雅典——就出自这个家族。于是她和姐姐一起去了雅典并在那里定居。当时，雅典是个非常大男子主义的地方，所以她被视为外国人。
And Athens is also an unbelievably kind of Taliban-esque place in its attitudes towards women. Yes, so it's... Women are very, veryordinate in in Athenian life they they do not have a public role to play at all the pub that the women who do kind of you know meet men and kind of hang out with them are called Tyra they're kind of very rather cortisans kind of very posh educated prostitutes and so there is this aspasia as this very high profile foreign woman is an obvious but for the
雅典在对待女性的态度上也是一个令人难以置信的、塔利班式的地方。是的，所以它……女性在雅典的生活中非常边缘化，她们根本没有扮演公共角色的空间。那些与男性见面并混在一起的女性被称为“海泰拉”（hetairai），她们是某种高级交际花，受过良好教育的高档妓女。因此，阿斯帕西亚作为这样一个备受瞩目的外国女性，自然成为了伯里克利的敌人们以及
mockery of pericles's enemies and for um comic dramatists like aristophanes. And so there is this kind of seam of abuse of Aspasia that she's either a high class courtesan or a low class courtesan, a low class courtesan. And there are stories that she actually runs a brothel. And Aristophanes accuses Aspasia of starting the Peloponnesian War, the war between Athens and Sparta, which ends up ruining Athens, because she becomes Pericles' mistress. And the story goes that people from a city called Megara have stolen three prostitutes from Aspasia's brothel and it's in vengeance for that that
像阿里斯托芬（Aristophanes）这样的喜剧剧作家们嘲笑的对象。于是，围绕阿斯帕西亚涌现出了一股恶意的浪潮，说她要么是高级交际花，要么是低级交际花。甚至有传言说她其实经营着一家妓院。阿里斯托芬指责阿斯帕西亚挑起了伯罗奔尼撒战争（Peloponnesian War）——这场最终毁了雅典的雅典与斯巴达之间的战争——因为她成了伯里克利的情妇。传闻说来自墨加拉（Megara）城的人从阿斯帕西亚的妓院里偷了三个妓女，正是为了报复这一点，
Pericles introduces a trade embargo against Megara which in turn sets up a kind of domino effect which culminates in the Peloponnesian war. Now is this true that there is a very different way to look at Aspasia and that is to say that she is a person who has an absolutely seismic influence on the two aspects of Athens for which it's best known in its golden age. The first is politically, and the second is in the dimension of philosophy. So Aspasia becomes the mistress of Pericles, the most powerful man in Athens. Pericles is obsessed by her. He can't marry her because of a rule, a law that he himself has introduced, which says that Athenian men can't marry foreign women. But basically, they kind of live as effectively as man and wife. He is notorious for kissing her in public.
伯里克利对墨加拉实施了贸易禁运，这反过来引发了一种多米诺骨牌效应，最终导致了伯罗奔尼撒战争的爆发。现在，这是真的吗？其实看待阿斯帕西亚还有一种截然不同的方式，那就是：她在雅典黄金时代最为人所知的两个方面产生了绝对震撼性的影响。第一方面是政治，第二方面是哲学维度。阿斯帕西亚成了伯里克利的情妇，伯里克利是雅典最有权势的人。伯里克利对她着迷不已。由于他自己引入的一条法律规定雅典男子不得与外国女性结婚，他无法娶她。但基本上，他们实际上就像夫妻一样生活在一起。他以在公共场合亲吻她而闻名。
He's notorious for kissing her every day. This is noted by Plutarch centuries later as a kind of weird aberration. You know, kissing the same woman endlessly. Wouldn't have happened in Persia. No. If it only moved across the Aegean, eh? But it's an interesting point
他以每天都亲吻她而闻名。几个世纪后，普鲁塔克（Plutarch）将此记录为一种奇怪的越轨行为。（心想：）你知道，没完没了地亲吻同一个女人。这在波斯是绝对不会发生的。不。要是这习俗能传过爱琴海就好了，对吧？但这确实是一个有趣的点，
about how badly women are treated in Athens, actually, because, I mean, of course, you know... Yeah, it's much more liberating in Persia. I think it's an interesting point about how badly women are treated in Athens, actually, because, I mean, of course, you know... Yeah, it's much more liberated in Persia. I think it's really tough. But according to Plato, it's Aspasia who actually writes the famous funeral oration that Pericles gives, which is recorded in Thucydides' history, over the war dead in the first years of the Peloponnesian War. So there's this kind of...
关于雅典女性受到的待遇有多么糟糕，因为，当然，你知道……是的，波斯要解放得多。我认为这是一个有趣的点，关于雅典女性受到的待遇有多么糟糕，因为，当然，你知道……是的，波斯要解放得多。我觉得这真的很艰难。但根据柏拉图（Plato）的说法，实际上是阿斯帕西亚撰写了伯里克利那篇著名的葬礼演说——这篇演说被记录在修昔底德（Thucydides）的历史著作中，是为了悼念伯罗奔尼撒战争初期的阵亡将士。所以存在这样一种……
So even the kind of Aristophanian joke about Aspasia starting the Peloponnesian War, it's casting her as a political player. And the idea of a woman as a serious contributor towards Athenian political life, I mean, is staggering, absolutely staggering. But on top of that, there's the possibility that she stands as the fountainhead of the entire Western philosophical tradition. And this is the thesis of a wonderful book by the Oxford classicist, Armand D'Angour, who wrote a book, Socrates in Love. And he argues that, well, basically before Pericles,
因此，甚至连阿里斯托芬关于阿斯帕西亚挑起伯罗奔尼撒战争的笑话，实际上也是把她塑造成了一个政治玩家。一个女人能够作为严肃的贡献者参与到雅典的政治生活中，我的意思是，这太惊人了，绝对是惊世骇俗。但除此之外，还有一种可能性：她可能是整个西方哲学传统的发源地。这是牛津大学古典学者阿曼·当古尔（Armand D'Angour）在其一本精彩著作《爱中的苏格拉底》（Socrates in Love）中所提出的论点。他认为，在伯里克利之前，
Aspasia had a relationship with Socrates. And again, from Plutarch, rydym wedi'i ddweud bod Socrates yn y great theory of love. And Socrates says that his philosophy of love derives from a woman called Diatima. He says, everything that I have learned, I learned long ago, you know, when I was a young man, from this very, very clever, brilliant woman. Who is Diatima? Armand's argument is that Diatima, it means honored by Zeus. Pericles' nickname was Zeus, a bit like Macron calls himself Jupiter, Pericles was known as Zeus, and that Diotima is Aspasia, and that therefore you can make the case that you've got Aristotle, Plato, Socrates, Aspasia, that Aspasia stands at the head of this entire tradition, you know, which
阿斯帕西亚曾与苏格拉底有过一段情。同样，根据普鲁塔克的记载，苏格拉底曾讲述过关于爱的伟大理论。苏格拉底说，他的爱情哲学源自一个名叫狄奥提玛（Diotima）的女人。他说，我所学到的一切，很久以前当我还是个年轻人时，就从这位非常、非常聪明、才华横溢的女性身上学到了。谁是狄奥提玛？阿曼的论点是，狄奥提玛的意思是“受宙斯尊敬的人”。伯里克利的绰号就叫“宙斯”——有点像马克龙（Macron）自称为“朱庇特”一样，伯里克利被称为“宙斯”——而狄奥提玛就是阿斯帕西亚，因此你可以这样论证：亚里士多德、柏拉图、苏格拉底、阿斯帕西亚，阿斯帕西亚就站在整个传统的顶端，你知道，这……
is an absolutely brilliant thesis, absolutely stunning. The reason that I haven't put Aspasia in at number one is because I think it's unproven and the counter view is that basically we know nothing about Aspasia at all. So because... A good Greek myth. Yeah, well this is a problem.. If Dominic were here, he'd just be kind of going, yeah, well, there's a problem with ancient history. I'm going to tell my inner Dominic any moment now. But I'm slightly puzzled. I mean, you know, I must say...
这个论点绝对太精彩了，简直惊艳。我之所以没有把阿斯帕西亚排在第一位，是因为我认为这还没有得到证实，而相反的观点基本上是我们对阿斯帕西亚一无所知。所以因为…… 一个精彩的希腊神话。对，这确实是个问题…… 如果多米尼克在这里，他大概会说，好吧，古代史就是有点问题。我随时准备唤醒我内心的多米尼克。但我有点疑惑。我是说，你知道，我必须说……
Well, because all this stuff... Let's talk about this relationship with Socrates. I mean, Socrates was not renowned for being a great sort of, how shall we say, seducer of... Yeah, but as a young man, as a young man. And he talks about this woman that he... She must have been in love with his intellect, I presume. Well, as a young man, I'm sure, you know, he's a...
嗯，因为所有这些东西…… 我们来谈谈她与苏格拉底的关系。我是说，苏格拉底可不是以那种伟大的、怎么说呢、诱惑…… 对，但作为年轻人时，作为年轻人时。他谈到这个女人时…… 我想她一定爱慕他的才华。好吧，作为一个年轻人，我确信，你知道，他是一个……
Yeah. Yeah, no, I mean, we know he fights and... Certainly in the Muslim tradition, Socrates is not considered to be particularly... And is there a Persian dimension to Aspasia? Well, there is, there is, now that you mention it. Which might actually go to the argument that she may well have certainly existed. I don't know about the influence that you claim she held.
对。对，不，我是说，我们知道他打过仗，而且…… 在穆斯林传统中，苏格拉底肯定不被认为特别…… 那么阿斯帕西亚有波斯背景吗？嗯，有的，有的，既然你提到了。这其实可以支持她确实存在的论点。至于你所说的她拥有的影响力，我持保留态度。
But Cyrus the Younger, who was the satrap, the governor of Western Anatolia, he apparently named his mistress after her as a sort of emulation, so to speak, which is quite interesting, actually, in that sense. So he obviously thought that she was someone of significance. So the Persian seal of approval as well. Lydia.
但是小居鲁士，也就是安纳托利亚西部的总督，显然以她的名字给他的情妇命名，可以说是出于一种效仿，从某种意义上说，这其实挺有趣的。所以他显然认为她是一个举足轻重的人物。因此这也得到了波斯的认可。莉迪亚。
So I think she deserves to be at number three. Were the evidence a little bit firmer, she'd be in at number one. And the Peloponnesian War, remind me, who benefited from the Peloponnesian War? The Spartans. And who were the supporters of the Spartans? The Persians. Thank you. Yes anyway let's move on. She must have been important, she must have been important because she she basically she basically facilitated the destruction of Athens which is...
所以我认为她理应排在第三位。如果证据再确凿一点，她就能排在第一位了。还有伯罗奔尼撒战争，提醒我一下，谁从伯罗奔尼撒战争中获益了？斯巴达人。谁又是斯巴达人的支持者？波斯人。谢谢。好啦，无论如何我们继续吧。她一定很重要，她一定很重要，因为她基本上促成了雅典的毁灭，这……
Okay so that's why she's at three and not at one. Exactly, there you are. OK. So, number two. Ah, right. Number two, just bubbling under, we have... Marie Waleska. Now... And this is your choice, Ali. This is my choice, yeah. Because I think she plays a very, very important role, actually, in the history of Europe and certainly in the history of Napoleonic Europe. So tell us who she is.
好吧，这就是为什么她排在第三而不是第一。没错，就是这样。好的。那么，第二位。啊，对了。第二位，正蓄势待发的是…… 玛丽·瓦莱夫斯卡。现在…… 这是你的选择，阿里。这是我的选择，对。因为我认为她在欧洲历史，尤其是拿破仑时代的欧洲历史中，扮演了非常非常重要的角色。那么给我们讲讲她是谁吧。
Marie Waleska was the wife of a Polish nobleman. A very old one. A very old Polish nobleman. A very old one, wasn't he? A very old Polish nobleman, it has to be said, who, when Napoleon goes careering across Europe and defeats the Prussians and then the Russians and he's heading into what is now Poland, the Polish noblemen gather round and encourage Marie Valeska. They sort of say,
玛丽·瓦莱夫斯卡是一位波兰贵族的妻子。一个非常古老的家族。一位非常古老的波兰贵族。非常古老的一位，不是吗？不得不说，是一位非常古老的波兰贵族。当拿破仑横扫欧洲、击败普鲁士人和俄罗斯人、正向现在的波兰挺进时，波兰贵族们聚拢过来，鼓励玛丽·瓦莱夫斯卡。他们大概是这么说的：
if you want to do your duty for your country, to your country, we would encourage you to engage in, basically, to become Napoleon's mistress. And if you become Napoleon's mistress, it will further the cause of Polish independence, because then he will have a very personal interest in all this. Now, I don't know how much of that is realistic, but certainly he became infatuated with her. He was certainly very taken by her. And she did indeed become his mistress. And then, of course, Napoleon did then set up from the conquest the Grand Duchy of Warsaw, which was going to be then the sort of fledgling, I mean, the anticipation was, was that he would recreate the Kingdom of Poland, which had been divided amongst the empires of Russia, Prussia and Austria.
如果你想为你的国家尽忠，为国家效力，我们鼓励你去做这样一件事——基本上就是成为拿破仑的情妇。如果你成了拿破仑的情妇，这将推动波兰独立的事业，因为这样一来，他对这一切就会有非常私人的兴趣。现在，我不知道其中有多少是现实的，但毫无疑问，他确实对她着迷了。他显然非常倾心于她。她也确实成了他的情妇。然后，当然，拿破仑接着在征服的土地上建立了华沙大公国，这本来将成为一个雏形——我的意思是，当时的预期是他将重建波兰王国，这个王国此前已被俄罗斯、普鲁士和奥地利帝国瓜分。
So she plays quite an important role in that, I think a very strong political role. She became, despite her reluctance to begin with, I think very fond of Napoleon, and actually was the one person to visit him on Elba when he was in exile in 1814, although I don't think he was terribly responsive, I have to say. But he has the interest, the other interesting thing, I suppose, is that he does have a son by her, which convinces him then that, of course, the problem is not with him,
所以在其中她扮演了相当重要的角色，我认为是一个非常强有力的政治角色。尽管一开始有些不情愿，但她后来对拿破仑产生了深厚的感情，实际上也是1814年拿破仑流放厄尔巴岛时唯一去探望他的人，尽管我得说，拿破仑当时似乎并不是特别热络。不过，另一个有趣的事情是，我想，她确实为他生了一个儿子，这让他确信，问题当然不在他身上，
but with Josephine, and therefore the divorce with Josephine goes ahead, and he then marries into the Austrian, the Habsburg royal family. But I think she's significant, really, for, I suppose, this important role she plays in European history and the influence she obviously has on Napoleon. The son, Alexander, I mean, you know, she's then looked after, you know, after Napoleon goes into exile finally in St Helena, and she's, you know, the descendants are still with us. So it's not as if she was thrown aside.
而是在约瑟芬身上，因此与约瑟芬的离婚得以推进，随后他迎娶了奥地利的哈布斯堡皇室成员。但我认为她之所以重要，是因为她在欧洲历史中扮演了这一重要角色，以及她对拿破仑显然产生的影响。那个儿子亚历山大——我是说，你知道的，拿破仑最终被流放到圣赫勒拿岛后，她受到了照顾，而且你知道，她的后代至今仍在。所以她并不是那种被抛弃的人。
I mean, when Napoleon III comes back in, and the descendants of Alexander and others are well catered for. So it's quite an influential, I think, an influential relationship in that sense. There's a brilliant thing I just read just before coming out that Napoleon was in Warsaw when he met her. Yeah. And he had invited Josephine to come to Warsaw.
我是说，当拿破仑三世复辟时，亚历山大和其他人的后代都得到了很好的照顾。所以从这个意义上说，这是一段相当有影响力的关系。我刚好在来这里之前读到了一件非常精彩的事：拿破仑在华沙时遇到了她。对。他曾邀请约瑟芬来华沙。
But then he said no. He said, I'm busy now. No, he didn't. No, he didn't. What he said to Josephine was, I love you with all my heart, but the winter is terrible. Yeah, that's right. It would be far too cold for you to go. Yeah, yeah. So disgraceful behaviour from Napoleon. And do you know what the Countess Pataki said about Marie?
但后来他说不。他说，我现在很忙。不，他没这么说。不，他没这么说。他对约瑟芬说的是，我全心全意爱着你，但冬天的天气太糟糕了。对，没错。对你来说去那里太冷了。对，对。拿破仑的行为真是不光彩。你知道波塔基伯爵夫人对玛丽是怎么说的吗？
No. Gorgeous but thick. Oh, really? So that's the counter view view is that perhaps she just got she just got lucky she's got well i mean i agree i think that that that she she clearly you know she didn't get involved she did her duty because she was very pious she was very pious catholic and um she was obviously i mean in fairness her husband was was i think twice or almost three times her age.
不知道。美艳但没脑子。哦，真的吗？所以相反的观点是，也许她只是运气好，她只是…… 好吧，我是说，我同意，我认为她显然，你知道，她并没有刻意卷入，她只是在尽自己的职责，因为她非常虔诚，是一个非常虔诚的天公教徒，而且嗯，很明显，平心而论，她丈夫的年龄大概是她的两倍甚至将近三倍。
I don't think he was overblown by that. He was 52 years older than her, apparently. Yeah, 52 years older. But the idea that a delegation of Polish noblemen would come up to you and sort of say, look, I really think you need to take one for the team. Yeah. Off you go.
我觉得他并没有因此被夸大。显然他比她大52岁。对，大52岁。但是一帮波兰贵族代表走到你面前对你说，听着，我真的觉得你得为团队作出牺牲。对。你去吧。
Yeah. And, you know, she's obviously, you know, not entirely... I mean, I think partly she's slightly in awe of this individual. But it does turn out to be one of the great love affairs. I mean, in fairness, it does turn out to be one. So I think she's in it too because, you know, compared to Napoleon, she's obviously a very obscure person. Yeah, absolutely.
对，而且，你知道，她显然，你知道，并非完全…… 我想部分是因为她对这个人有点敬畏。但它最终确实演变成了一场伟大的爱情故事。平心而论，它确实成了一场伟大的爱情。所以我认为她能排在第二位是因为，与拿破仑相比，她显然是一个非常默默无闻的人。对，绝对是的。
And she achieves great things for her country. It's a kind of heroic thing to have done. I mean, the only thing I would, the only, you know, the caveat know the caveat i'd have i suppose with them why she's probably not number one is that you know would napoleon have have recreated the grand duchy warsaw or helped without her probably yes i mean i think that would i mean this probably just edge things along yes okay so number one is someone who indisputably yeah now this does have an impact qualitatively indisputably has a seismic impact on the course of history, and who, perhaps more than anyone else in the list, comes from nowhere. So she comes from nowhere to shape the destiny, not just of nations, but of continents.
她为自己的国家成就了伟大的事业。这是一种很英勇的壮举。我是说，我唯一要说的，我唯一的，你知道，我所保留的顾虑，我想关于她为什么可能不是第一位的原因是，你知道，拿破仑没有她会重建华沙大公国或者提供帮助吗？大概也会吧。我的意思是，这大概只会起到一点推波助澜的作用吧。好吧，那么第一位是一个无可争议的…… 对，这确实产生了影响，从性质上讲，无可争议地对历史进程产生了震撼性的影响，而且与名单上的其他人相比，她可以说是凭空出现的。她从无名之中崛起，不仅塑造了各个国家，甚至塑造了整个大陆的命运。
And our number one is La Melinche and La Melinche for those who don't know she she's born on the edge of the Aztec Empire just before the Spanish arrive. She is, we don't, so the measure of the obscurity from which she comes is we don't know her original name. We know that she was the daughter of a nobleman. Probably her mother was a slave. This is a community that is kind of constantly overshadowed by the expansionism of the Aztecs. And when she's still quite a young girl, so maybe seven or eight, she gets sold into slavery. Perhaps her parents are forced to do it. Perhaps she gets kind of, you know, given as a way of trying to buy off Aztec aggression so she gets taken to a great kind of slave Mart she gets bought by the mayor and people of the mayor the Tabasco and the river Tabasco as in the
我们排名第一的是拉马林切（La Malinche）。对于那些不了解的人，她出生在阿兹特克帝国的边缘，就在西班牙人到达之前不久。我们甚至不知道她的原名，可见她曾经是多么默默无闻。我们知道她是一个贵族的女儿。她的母亲可能是一个奴隶。这是一个不断被阿兹特克的扩张主义所蒙阴的群体。当她还是个相当小的女孩时，大概七八岁，她就被卖为奴隶。也许她的父母是被迫这么做的。也许她被当作试图收买阿兹特克侵略者的筹码送出去了，于是她被带到了一个大型奴隶市场，被玛雅人和塔巴斯科河畔的人买了下来，也就是……
Mexican well she actually has to take herself? No she's not. She's from one of these tribes that are subjugated by the Aztec. Yes so she's kind of on the, yeah absolutely and this is really important to what then happens. So she gets brought up as a slave there, again we don't know what name she has as a slave but she speaks Nahuatl, the language of the Aztecs and of that kind of band. She goes, she learns Maya, and then the Spanish arrive. And they, basically the people who own her
墨西哥的那条…… 她其实是自愿去的吗？不是。她来自那些被阿兹特克征服的部落之一。是的，所以她有点处在边缘，对，绝对是的，这对于接下来发生的事情非常重要。所以她在那里作为奴隶被抚养长大，同样，我们不知道她作为奴隶时的名字，但她会说纳瓦特尔语，也就是阿兹特克人和那一带的语言。她学会了玛雅语，然后西班牙人到了。他们，基本上拥有她的人
are so intimidated that they make an offering of 20 slaves to the Spanish, And this girl is one of them. And this is the making of her because present in the Spanish ranks is a Spaniard called Jerónimo de Aguilar who had been a slave himself. He'd been captured by the mayor. So he speaks one of the
被吓坏了，以至于他们向西班牙人进献了20名奴隶，而这个女孩就是其中之一。这成就了她，因为在西班牙人的队伍中有一个叫赫罗尼莫·德·阿吉拉尔（Jerónimo de Aguilar）的西班牙人，他自己也曾是个奴隶。他曾被玛雅人俘虏。所以他会说一种
Mayan languages and so this means that the Spanish can start to communicate because this girl speaks Mayan the Spaniard speaks Mayan and so the Spaniards can start to communicate so does she learn Spanish of him well hold the comfort so she gets given the name of the crew she gets converted you make baptized gets given the name marina the the the people of Central America they transliterate this as Melina they start to call her Melina sin which is a, which is a way of dignifying her name. And Du calls the Spanish again, kind of Hispanicizes and call her La Melincha. And the key turning moment in her life is when the Spaniards with Hern Cortes, the leader,
玛雅方言，这就意味着西班牙人可以开始沟通了，因为这个女孩会说玛雅语，这个西班牙人会说玛雅语，于是西班牙人就可以开始交流了——那么她是从他那里学会西班牙语的吗？嗯，等等看，所以她被赐予了名字…… 她皈依了天主教，受洗并被赋予了玛雅（Marina）这个名字，中美洲的人民将其音译为玛丽娜辛（Melinasin），这是一种尊称她的名字的方式。而迪亚斯（Diaz）又把西班牙语化，称她为拉马林查（La Malincha）。她人生的关键转折点是，当以埃尔南·科尔特斯（Hernán Cortés）为首领的西班牙人
go back up towards where they're going to launch the expedition against the Aztecs. Go to Tenochtitlan, the great capital, attack Moctezuma. I'm impressed you said that. Thank you. Well, we did a wonderful episode with Camilla Townsend on this, so I had to practice for that. And there it turns out that Aguilar does not speak Nahuatl right and Cortes is furious about this because they can't communicate and then La Malinche steps forward and says I can I can speak Nahuatl so you have this kind of chain that as as the Spaniards march towards Tenochtitlan
重新北上，准备对阿兹特克人发起远征。前往伟大的首都特诺奇蒂特兰（Tenochtitlan），进攻蒙特苏马（Moctezuma）。你能说出这个我印象深刻。谢谢。好吧，我们之前和卡米拉·汤森（Camilla Townsend）做过一期精彩的节目，所以我为此练习过。结果证明阿吉拉尔其实不会说纳瓦特尔语，科尔特斯对此非常愤怒，因为他们无法交流，这时拉马林切站出来说，我会，我会说纳瓦特尔语。所以就形成了这样一条链条：当西班牙人向特诺奇蒂特兰进军时，
La Malinche will translate from Nahuatl, will translate into Maya, Aguilar will then translate it into Spanish. But as they go, La Malinche is very, very smart. She starts to learn Spanish. Aguilar gets cut out. La Malinche essentially becomes the interface for Cortes and everybody in the Aztec empire. Now, some these of course are the enemies, the Aztecs themselves, but for La Melinche this is a chance to get back at the Aztecs and so it's La Melinche who basically constructs the alliance that enables the Spanish to defeat the Aztec Empire because there are all kinds of subject peoples who are desperate to revolt and it's La Militia who is not only a brilliant linguist but a brilliant diplomat who essentially stitches this stitches this this this
拉马林切将纳瓦特尔语翻译成玛雅语，然后阿吉拉尔再将其翻译成西班牙语。但随着行程的推进，拉马林切非常非常聪明。她开始学习西班牙语。阿吉拉尔就被排挤出去了。拉马林切基本上成为了科尔特斯与阿兹特克帝国所有人之间的桥梁。当然，其中一些人是敌人，也就是阿兹特克人本身，但对于拉马林切来说，这是向阿兹特克人复仇的机会，所以正是拉马林切构建了使西班牙人能够击败阿兹特克帝国的联盟，因为有各种各样的臣服民族渴望起义，而拉马林切不仅是一位杰出的语言学家，更是一位出色的外交家，她基本上将这个联盟
alliance together because I mean the number of Spaniards were talking about what 500 yeah they're very very very very few so La Militia is recognized by the Spaniards themselves as having played absolutely key role so she has it she has this relationship with with Cortes he has a son by him Martin Cortes who for Mexicans to this day serves as the kind of fountainhead of the the the the mixing of the European and the Central American. So he's kind of seen as the first Mexican, if you like, in that kind of, you know,
缝合在了一起。因为我是说，我们谈论的西班牙人数量是多少，大约500人？对，非常非常少，所以拉马林切被西班牙人公认为发挥了绝对关键的作用。她与科尔特斯保持着这种关系，并为他生了一个儿子马丁·科尔特斯（Martin Cortés），对于今天的墨西哥人来说，他被视为欧洲与中美洲文化融合的源头。所以他被视为现代墨西哥的第一个人，如果你愿意这么看的话，
the first embodiment of modern Mexico. And she is seen by Mexicans today in a very ambivalent light. So is she a traitor? But this is- So for lots of Mexicans, she's seen as the embodiment of a traitor. But for lots of Mexicans, she's seen as someone who basically creates Mexico. And she has this huge, huge influence on Cortes, on the Spanish, and on the Aztecs,
也就是现代墨西哥的最初化身。而今天的墨西哥人对她的看法则非常矛盾。那么她是一个叛徒吗？但这又是——所以对许多墨西哥人来说，她被视为叛徒的化身。但对许多其他墨西哥人来说，她被视为基本上创造了墨西哥的人。她对科尔特斯、对西班牙人、对阿兹特克人，
and on all the other various Nahuatl-speaking people. You can only really, this interests me, you can only really see her as a traitor if you look at her through the prism of modern nationalism, surely. I mean, that's the thing. And you can see her, but from the perspective of 16th century Mexico, she was probably taking revenge
以及对所有其他讲纳瓦特尔语的各个部族都有着巨大无比的影响。你只有通过现代民族主义的有色眼镜来看待她，才会真正认为她是一个叛徒，这绝对是肯定的。我的意思是，就是这样。如果你从16世纪墨西哥的角度来看，她可能只是在为她的人民多年来所遭受的对待复仇。
for the way her people had been treated for many, many years. And it's really striking that she, for instance, she never adopts a European dress. That's interesting. She always wears... She's recounted in Diaz's Conquest of New Spain, is that right? Absolutely. And he says that she's a hugely admirable figure.
非常引人注目的是，例如，她从未穿过欧洲服装。这很有趣。她总是穿着…… 迪亚斯的《征服新西班牙史》里有关于她的记载，对吗？绝对是的。他说她是一个极其令人钦佩的人物。
Cortés himself says that he owes, obviously, for the conquest of Mexico, he owes most to God, but then he owes most to La Melinche. I mean, it's seismic when you think about it. I mean, the role she plays and the conquest of New Spain and basically the establishment of the Spanish Empire in America is, well... Yeah. I don't think you can beat that, really. No, and she establishes a school of translators.
科尔特斯本人也表示，对于征服墨西哥，他最感激的当然是上帝，其次最感激的就是拉马林切。我的意思是，仔细想想，这太震撼了。我是说，她在征服新西班牙以及基本上在美洲建立西班牙帝国过程中所扮演的角色，真是…… 是的。我想你真的无法超越这一点。不，她还建立了一所翻译学校。
Wow. So she's the person basically who enables, you know, the two sides to communicate. She is kind of cheerful. She's charming. Basically everybody loves her. I mean, everybody who meets her loves her. So presumably Cortes had a wife in Spain? Yes, and so he can't... That's a long way away. No, he loves her. I mean, everybody who meets her loves her. So presumably, Cortés had a wife in Spain?
哇。所以她基本上就是那个让双方能够沟通的人。她很开朗。她很有魅力。基本上每个人都喜欢她。我是说，每一个见过她的人都喜欢她。那么presumably科尔特斯在西班牙有妻子吗？是的，所以他不能…… 那是很久以前的事了。不，他爱她。我是说，每一个见过她的人都喜欢她。所以，据推测，科尔特斯在西班牙有个妻子？
Yes, and so he can't... That's a long way away. No, he's not going to marry her, but he does marry her to a kind of very well-bred conquistador, which then means that she is recognised as a donna, a lady by the Spaniards. So Cortés kind of does right by her. And she dies very young,
是的，所以他不能…… 那是很久以前的事了。不，他不会娶她，但他把她嫁给了一位出身名门的征服者（conquistador），这意味着她被西班牙人公认为“多娜”（Donna），也就是一位贵妇。所以科尔特斯对她还算不错。她很年轻就去世了，
but having achieved incredible, incredible things. And I think that she's number one. I mean, we all agreed that she should be number one because, as you say, she comes from nowhere. She's a slave. She's a nameless slave. We don't know what her name was as a slave or before she became enslaved.
但却成就了不可思议、难以置信的伟业。我认为她当之无愧是第一位。我的意思是，我们都同意她应该排在第一位，因为正如你所说，她凭空出现。她是个奴隶。她是一个没有名字的奴隶。我们甚至不知道她作为奴隶时的名字，或者在她沦为奴隶之前的名字是什么。
And she rises to have this outsized impact on the history of Mexico, on the history of Spain, on the history of the world. and she rises to have this outsized impact on the history of Mexico, on the history of Spain, on the history of the world. So I think that La Melinche shows just how far a mistress can go. Well, I mean, we started with a slave who did basically nothing. Yes. And we've ended with a slave who enabled the conquest of the Aztec Empire,
而她崛起并对墨西哥历史、西班牙历史乃至世界历史产生了巨大深远的影响。而她崛起并对墨西哥历史、西班牙历史乃至世界历史产生了巨大深远的影响。所以我认为拉马林切展现了一个情妇究竟能走多远。好吧，我的意思是，我们从一个基本上什么也没做的奴隶开始。是的。而我们以一个促成了征服阿兹特克帝国的奴隶结束，
which is, yeah, I said, I mean, I said, I agree. I mean, I think her influence is outsized, really. I mean, it's enormous. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych.
这真是，就像我说的，我同意。我是说，我认为她的影响力实在是太巨大了。我是说，太惊人了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。
Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Mae'n wych. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。